Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
有些旅行住Airbnb体验更好。现在，你可以通过Airbnb探索加拿大及其众多的本地隐藏宝藏。我曾在加拿大断断续续工作了两年。是的。第一年，剧组给我安排了住处。第二年，我就想，嘿，不管那笔制作预算是多少，
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
能不能给我，让我自己去更有生活气息的街区找个住处？可以。我确实这么做了，我租了一间Airbnb，一个小公寓，正对着公园，非常可爱。我很喜欢那位房东，在那里住了两个月。哇。是的，而且离杂货店很近。
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
我真的感觉在那里过上了一种小生活。我在想加拿大落基山脉地区，那里有湖泊和阿尔伯塔省的落基山脉。不知道为什么，就觉得如果你在那里给自己弄个舒适的小木屋。你懂我的意思吗？是的。就像班夫国家公园。
Well listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. Whether it's a family member, listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. Whether it's a family member, friend or furry companion joining your summer road trip, enjoy the peace of mind that comes with Volvo's legendary safety. During Volvo Discover Days, enjoy limited time savings as you make plans to cruise through Muskoka or down Toronto's bustling streets. From now until June 30th, lease the 2025 Volvo XC60 from 1.74% and save up to $4,000. Condition supply. Visit your GTA Volvo retailer
听着，也许你应该考虑在下一次冒险中选择Airbnb。我是说，我们很喜欢它。非常喜欢。无论是家庭成员，听着，也许你应该考虑在下一次冒险中选择Airbnb。我是说，我们很喜欢它。非常喜欢。无论是家庭成员、朋友还是毛茸茸的伙伴加入你的夏季公路旅行，都能享受沃尔沃传奇安全性带来的安心。在沃尔沃探索日期间，享受限时优惠，计划前往穆斯科卡或穿梭在多伦多繁华的街道上。即日起至6月30日，租赁2025款沃尔沃XC60，利率低至1.74%，最高可节省4000美元。受条件限制。请访问您的GTA沃尔沃零售商
or go to volvocars.ca for full details. Hello and welcome to the second drink for grief counseling. Angela, you left me a message last week about this second drink share for today. And all you would say is that you could not believe what you found. You wouldn't tell me any other details. So I literally have no idea what you're about to share,
或访问volvocars.ca了解详情。你好，欢迎来到《悲伤辅导》的第二杯酒。安吉拉，你上周给我留了条语音，说今天要分享这第二杯酒。你只说你简直不敢相信自己发现了什么。你没告诉我任何其他细节。所以我真的完全不知道你要分享什么，
but I can wait no longer. Okay, I am pretty excited about this. So you guys remember when we first broke down the episode, not only did we discuss the fact that the Dunder Mifflin employees were having a bird funeral, but we both had crazy bird stories of our own. Yes. Mine happened while I was rewatching grief counseling
但我再也等不及了。好吧，我对此非常兴奋。大家还记得我们第一次拆解这一集时，不仅讨论了邓德·米夫林员工在举行鸟类葬礼的事实，而且我们俩都有自己疯狂的鸟类故事吗？是的。我的故事发生在我重温《悲伤辅导》时，
while I was preparing for the breakdown. Yours happened while you were actually recording this very podcast. I'm not gonna spoil the stories. I want you to hear them in real time. They do involve some birds, a squirrel, and a cat. That's all I'm going to say. Yes.
当时我正在准备拆解。你的故事发生在你录制这期播客的时候。我不会剧透这些故事。我希望你们能实时听到。它们确实涉及一些鸟、一只松鼠和一只猫。我就说这么多。是的。
My incident is cemented in our recording of grief counseling because, not to spoil anything, but my daughter pops into the podcast. We still talk about it. It was just really strange timing like all of it, but how does that connect to what you have to share? I'm so curious. Well, apparently, there are many of our listeners who believe that this particular podcast breakdown of grief counseling is cursed. What? I could not believe how many people wrote in about it. And they all have the craziest bird stories associated with listening to us break down grief counseling.
我的经历在录制《悲伤辅导》时被定格了，因为，不剧透任何内容，但我女儿突然闯进了播客。我们至今还在谈论这件事。这一切的时机真是太奇怪了，但这和你要分享的内容有什么联系？我太好奇了。好吧，显然，我们有很多听众认为这一期《悲伤辅导》的播客拆解是被诅咒的。什么？我简直不敢相信有多少人写信来谈论这件事。而且他们都有在听我们拆解《悲伤辅导》时发生的超级疯狂的鸟类故事。
Okay, wait. So when you were preparing grief counseling, you had a bird incident. When we were recording grief counseling, I had a bird incident. And now you're telling me that listeners had bird incidents while listening to grief counseling. Am I getting this right? You're getting this right. Okay. So, apparently grief counseling all together
好吧，等等。所以当你准备《悲伤辅导》时，你遇到了鸟类事件。当我们录制《悲伤辅导》时，我遇到了鸟类事件。现在你告诉我，听众在听《悲伤辅导》时也遇到了鸟类事件。我理解对了吗？你理解对了。好吧，所以显然《悲伤辅导》这一集
is cursed for birds. I have so many. Let's start with Darth underscore Gandalf, who wrote in to say, "'I wanted to reach out to tell you about what happened while listening to the grief counseling podcast episode. After Angela told us about how a squirrel killed a bird and then Jenna's cat had a bird in its mouth, a bird flew into my window.
对鸟类来说是被诅咒的。我有很多故事。让我们从Darth underscore Gandalf开始，他写道：“我想联系你们，告诉你们在听《悲伤辅导》播客那一集时发生了什么。在安吉拉告诉我们一只松鼠杀死了一只鸟，然后珍娜的猫嘴里叼着一只鸟之后，一只鸟飞进了我的窗户。
What? It wounded its wing but ended up being okay, but I thought that was so crazy and I needed to share. I love you guys so much. Oh my goodness. I guess that does kind of... I guess that kind of spoils what is in the episode. You'll still hear it.
什么？它翅膀受伤了，但最终没事，但我认为这太疯狂了，我必须分享一下。我非常爱你们。天哪。我想这确实有点……我想这确实有点剧透了这一集的内容。你们还是会听到的。
Next person was at HatchJolan who wrote in to say, I just listened to this one recently. And as I was listening to it, my kids caught my dog killing a bird. Oh my God. The next person. Amy Barbie wrote in to say, I listened to this episode yesterday.
下一个人是HatchJolan，他写道：我最近刚听了这一集。就在我听的时候，我的孩子们抓到我的狗正在杀死一只鸟。天哪。下一个人。Amy Barbie写道：我昨天听了这一集。
And in the same night, my dogs killed a pheasant. This is so creepy. Tara Jade 101 said, I absolutely love your podcast, but this episode is definitely cursed. My cat has never, in all caps, killed a bird and brought it back to my house until I was listening to this episode. Lady, this is nuts. I know. I'm not even done.
就在同一天晚上，我的狗杀死了一只野鸡。这太诡异了。Tara Jade 101说，我绝对喜欢你们的播客，但这一集绝对是被诅咒了。我的猫从来没有（全大写）杀死过鸟并带回家，直到我听这一集的时候。天哪，这太疯狂了。我知道。我还没说完呢。
Kristen Powers wrote in and said, y'all, I finished this podcast episode this morning and decided to head to our community pool for a little while afterward. There was, in all caps, a freaking dead bird floating in the water. Then she put three emojis, scary face, vomit face, crying face.
Kristen Powers写道，各位，我今天早上听完了这期播客，决定之后去我们的社区游泳池待一会儿。那里有（全大写）一只该死的死鸟漂在水面上。然后她放了三个表情符号，惊恐脸、呕吐脸、哭泣脸。
I don't know what is up with you guys and the bird curse, but I hope it's over soon. Sideways Laffy Face. EP Netter wrote in and said, I'm behind, but had to share. I just finished listening to Grief Counseling while going for a run and at the very end, finishing up the last stretch of my run, I passed a dead cardinal on the sidewalk. What is up? Fitting right in with the theme.
我不知道你们和鸟类诅咒是怎么回事，但我希望它快点结束。侧脸笑表情。EP Netter写道，我进度落后了，但必须分享一下。我刚在跑步时听完《悲伤辅导》，在最后，完成跑步的最后一段路时，我在人行道上经过了一只死红雀。这是怎么回事？正好符合主题。
Oh my gosh, this is someone who listened later. It doesn't matter apparently when you listen. Bethany0301 said, this episode is cursed. Just getting around to listening to this episode on my walk this morning and finishing up, I passed a dead yellow bird on the sidewalk that was not there when I began my walk. Oh my god.
天哪，这是一个后来才听的人。显然什么时候听并不重要。Bethany0301说，这一集被诅咒了。今天早上散步时才听这一集，快结束时，我在人行道上经过了一只死掉的黄鸟，我开始散步时它并不在那里。天哪。
Okay, JamieGirl19 said, I ended up listening to the podcast episode a few days late. But the night I listened to it, my mom saw a hawk eating a dove in her backyard. Lastly, Megatron wrote in and said, Oh my god, I never comment on anything like this. But I am so creeped out. I was listening to this episode on a run and there were two dead birds on my path. What is happening? Lady, should we even be rerunning it? I don't know.
好吧，JamieGirl19说，我晚了几天才听这期播客。但我听的那天晚上，我妈妈看到一只老鹰在后院吃一只鸽子。最后，Megatron写道，天哪，我从来不对这类事情发表评论。但我真的被吓坏了。我在跑步时听这一集，路上有两只死鸟。发生了什么？天哪，我们还应该重播它吗？我不知道。
I don't know. Isn't that so crazy? Oh my gosh. Okay. Well, I guess here is our second drink of grief counseling. Yeah, and hopefully it won't have the same bird curse effect this time around. Good luck everyone. I'm Jenna Fischer.
我不知道。这不是很疯狂吗？天哪。好吧，我想这就是我们《悲伤辅导》的第二杯酒。是的，希望这次不会有同样的鸟类诅咒效果。祝大家好运。我是珍娜·费舍尔。
And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hi, everybody.
我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。大家好。
Hello. Welcome to Office Ladies. I'm so excited about this episode. It's so good, right? Yeah, and we reached out to lots of folks. So we have some fun, fun stuff. This is grief counseling. And guys, if we can get you depressed by the end of this podcast, we've done our job.
你好。欢迎来到《办公室女士》。我对这一集感到非常兴奋。它太棒了，对吧？是的，我们联系了很多人。所以我们有一些非常有趣的内容。这一集是《悲伤辅导》。伙计们，如果我们能在播客结束时让你们感到沮丧，那我们的工作就完成了。
Oh, Michael. It's season three, episode four, written by Jen Salata and directed by Roger Nygaard. Jen Salata is one of my favorite people, Jenna. 100%. She is just such a delight and was so much fun on set because she would always crack up. Oh yeah. She was one of our worst laughers, which made her the best laugher.
哦，迈克尔。这是第三季第四集，由Jen Salata编剧，Roger Nygaard执导。Jen Salata是我最喜欢的人之一，珍娜。百分之百。她真是太可爱了，在片场非常有趣，因为她总是会笑场。哦，是的。她是我们要么最差的笑场者，这让她成为了最好的笑场者。
Yeah. Hey Jenna, you know what I'd love right now? I hope it's a summary. It's a summary! Whoop whoop! All right, here it is. Michael finds out that his former boss, Ed Truck, was decapitated in a self-induced drunk driving accident. Nobody seems upset though, or certainly
是的。嘿珍娜，你知道我现在想要什么吗？我希望是总结。是总结！呼呼！好了，就是这样。迈克尔发现他的前任老板埃德·卡车（Ed Truck）在一次自导自演的酒驾事故中被斩首了。然而似乎没人感到难过，或者至少
not upset enough, which causes Michael to question if anyone would care about his death. Of course, he doesn't know that that's what he's worried about. Yeah, he doesn't understand really the depths of his sadness. Yes. He wants everyone to love him and be sad for him if he wasn't around. Yeah, make a fuss about him. Well, first, he leads everyone in some grief counseling.
没有足够难过，这导致迈克尔质疑如果他去世了是否会有人关心。当然，他不知道这就是他担心的原因。是的，他并不真正理解他悲伤的深度。是的。他希望每个人都爱他，如果他不在了，大家会为他感到难过。是的，为他大惊小怪。好吧，首先，他带领大家进行了一些悲伤辅导。
But then later, he forces everyone to participate in a bird funeral. Meanwhile, over in Stanford, Jim is put in charge of supervising Karen for the day, but decides to put their work on hold so they can search for her favorite bag of chips. Oh, we're going to have so much to say about that. This is a really odd tangent, and I don't mean to take this really weird really fast. Do it.
但后来，他强迫每个人参加一场鸟类葬礼。与此同时，在斯坦福，吉姆被指派负责监督凯伦一天，但决定暂停工作，这样他们就可以去寻找她最喜欢的那袋薯片。哦，我们对此会有很多话要说。这是一个非常奇怪的题外话，我并不是想让这变得非常奇怪且非常快。做吧。
Jenna, while I was rewatching this episode, I hear a commotion outside of my That's What She Shed. No. And a squirrel is eating a little bird. That's worse than what I thought you were going to say. Yeah. And so I was like, wait, what's he eating? What's he eating? I start filming it.
珍娜，当我在重温这一集时，我听到外面有骚动。那是我的“她的小屋”（That's What She Shed）。不。一只松鼠正在吃一只小鸟。这比我想象的还要糟糕。是的。所以我当时想，等等，它在吃什么？它在吃什么？我开始拍摄它。
I have video of me filming this squirrel. And in the background, you can hear grief counseling and a bird funeral. Oh my God. It was like, it was so crazy. But apparently squirrels are like, they're like an opportunist, you know? If there's a little bird's nest, they go for a baby bird, they do it.
我有拍摄这只松鼠的视频。在背景音里，你可以听到《悲伤辅导》和鸟类葬礼的声音。天哪。这太疯狂了。但显然松鼠就像，它们就像机会主义者，你知道吗？如果有鸟巢，它们就会去抓小鸟，它们就是这样。
Squirrels are terrible. Everyone thinks they're so cute because of their fluffy tails, but they're awful. Look it up, everybody. Squirrels carry more disease than rats. Look it up. Okay, sorry, but it just was kind of crazy that I was watching an episode that had a bird funeral and then I saw a squirrel attack a bird. It was crazy.
松鼠太可怕了。每个人都因为它们毛茸茸的尾巴而认为它们很可爱，但它们很糟糕。去查查吧，各位。松鼠携带的疾病比老鼠还多。去查查吧。好吧，抱歉，但我看的那一集正好有鸟类葬礼，然后我看到一只松鼠攻击一只鸟，这真是太疯狂了。太疯狂了。
Yeah. Okay how do we get back from that? Hit me with some fast facts. Alright fast fact number one. This episode was written by Jen Salado, we said that, and Angela reached out to Jen for this episode. Yes, Jen and I traded emails and texts and she was so much fun to talk to about this episode. She was so excited to share information. And so she sent in a whole bunch of audio clips that we are going to play and she is going to come back as a full, awesome guest for maybe two episodes coming up Jenna. Ooh. Ooh.
是的。好吧，我们怎么从那件事中走出来？给我一些快讯。好的，快讯第一条。这一集是由Jen Salado编剧的，我们说过了，安吉拉联系了Jen来谈这一集。是的，Jen和我交换了电子邮件和短信，和她谈论这一集非常有趣。她非常兴奋能分享信息。所以她发来了一大堆音频片段，我们将播放这些片段，她可能会作为一位完整、很棒的嘉宾回来参加接下来的一两集，珍娜。噢。噢。
We're trying to figure out scheduling and whatnot, but she is in and I cannot wait. Well let's play her hello audio clip, Sam. Okay. Hey guys, it's Jen. I miss you. I'm loving your podcast. I am learning so much. I had no idea of the drama behind the scenes of Booze Cruise
我们正在努力确定日程安排之类的，但她已经答应了，我迫不及待了。好吧，让我们播放她的问候音频片段，萨姆。好的。嘿伙计们，我是Jen。我想你们了。我喜欢你们的播客。我学到了很多。我完全不知道《酒醉游轮》（Booze Cruise）幕后的戏剧性事件，
Where you were floating away at sea Angela with Phyllis and rain and Brian? Amazing anyway, I'm loving it and I'm gonna answer some grief counseling questions, so I'll send them in separate audio files Isn't it nice to hear her voice, Ange? I love her voice. I find her voice really soothing. Now, listen, we were chatting back and forth and I was listening to her voice a lot. And Jen, I think you have real good podcast voice. I know. Jen, are you doing voiceover work?
当时你们在海上漂流，安吉拉，还有菲利斯、雷恩和布莱恩？太神奇了，总之，我很喜欢它，我将回答一些关于《悲伤辅导》的问题，所以我将把它们放在单独的音频文件中。听到她的声音真好，安吉，我喜欢她的声音。我觉得她的声音真的很舒缓。现在，听着，我们一直在聊天，我听了很多次她的声音。Jen，我觉得你有很好的播客声音。我知道。Jen，你在做配音工作吗？
Like I'd buy anything you're selling with your voice. Or just call me and talk to me at the end of my day. Just leave me a message every day, just kind of telling me what you did. Yeah. Because I will listen to that as I like do the dishes. I agree. And Angela, in one of the clips that Jen sent, she explains a little bit about the process of writing this episode for her, right? Yeah, it's so fascinating. Sam, can you play it? Enjoy Jen's voice, everyone.
你用你的声音卖什么我都会买。或者只是给我打电话，在我一天结束时和我聊聊天。每天给我留个言，告诉我你做了什么。是的。因为我会在洗碗的时候听那个。我同意。而且安吉拉，在Jen发来的其中一个片段中，她解释了一点关于她写这一集的过程，对吧？是的，太迷人了。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？享受Jen的声音吧，各位。
One thing about this episode that really stuck with me personally was it was a thrill because it was hard to tell stories on other shows about characters going through internal things. And in this case with Michael, it was even more than that because this character was going through something internal and he was unaware of it, which made it really exciting to write because I love internal stories, but it also made it kind of difficult to explain at times.
关于这一集，有一件事让我个人印象深刻，那就是这很令人兴奋，因为在其他节目中讲述角色经历内心挣扎的故事很难。而在迈克尔的这个案例中，甚至不止于此，因为这个角色正在经历一些内心的事情，而他自己却浑然不知，这使得写作变得非常令人兴奋，因为我喜欢内心故事，但这也使得有时很难解释。
And I remember that I created a little chart where it said, here's what Michael is doing and saying in the scene, and then in bold under it, I wrote what was actually happening to Michael underneath it all. And of course, Steve got it all intuitively, and he's a genius.
我记得我做了一张小图表，上面写着迈克尔在场景中正在做什么和说什么，然后在它下面用粗体写着迈克尔在这一切之下实际上正在发生什么。当然，史蒂夫凭直觉就理解了一切，他是个天才。
It was such a treat to be able to write and tell that kind of story. And then, Jenna, to have you be aware of what it was intuitively and he's a genius. It was such a treat to be able to write and tell that kind of story. And then Jenna, to have you be aware of what it was that was going on with Michael, to have Pam sort of sense it and see it and fix it without it being spoken was just such a delight as a writer. Isn't that amazing? I love it.
能够写出并讲述那样的故事真是一种享受。然后，珍娜，让你凭直觉意识到迈克尔身上发生了什么，让帕姆在不言而喻的情况下感知到它、看到它并修复它，作为一名编剧，这真是太令人高兴了。这不是很神奇吗？我喜欢它。
I love that she had like secret notes and charts in her script about the emotional journey of characters. Yeah I find all that so interesting just like the writers process and what she wrote and how then it ended up playing you know. Oh my gosh, Angela, I just realized something. What? She was tracking. She was tracking. Tracking Michael's emotional journey. She tracked it. All right. Well, we are going to hear more from Jen throughout the episode.
我喜欢她在剧本里有关于角色情感旅程的秘密笔记和图表。是的，我发现这一切都非常有趣，就像编剧的过程以及她写的内容，然后最终呈现出来的方式，你知道。天哪，安吉拉，我刚刚意识到一件事。什么？她在追踪。她在追踪。追踪迈克尔的情感旅程。她追踪了它。好吧。那么，我们将在整集中听到更多来自Jen的内容。
So Jenna, why don't you fast-fact me? Okay. I'm calling fast-fact number two, the big fight. Oh, you did a shoulder shimmy. I know. Are you intrigued? I am. In Mindy Kaling's book, Is Everyone Hanging Out Without Me, she writes a chapter about working on the office
所以珍娜，为什么不给我来个快讯呢？好的。我称之为快讯第二条，大争吵。哦，你抖了抖肩膀。我知道。你感兴趣吗？我是。在敏迪·卡灵的书《每个人都在没我的时候聚会吗？》（Is Everyone Hanging Out Without Me）中，她写了一章关于在《办公室》工作
and being a writer and also being a performer. And she said in her book that she and Greg Daniels got into such a huge fight during this episode that she stormed off the set. She kicked his car. Yes. Yes. Oh, that's so good, I forgot about that.
以及作为一名编剧同时也是一名表演者的内容。她在书中说，她和格雷格·丹尼尔斯在这一集期间吵了一架，以至于她冲出了片场。她踢了他的车。是的。是的。哦，那太棒了，我忘了那件事了。
But rather than have me read you the passage, Angela, wouldn't you rather hear it in Mindy's voice? Yes. Well, guess what? What? There's an audio book. Oh, oh my God, oh my God, hit play, Sam, I wanna hear it. All right, here is the clip from the audio book
但与其让我为你读这段话，安吉拉，你难道不想听听敏迪的声音吗？是的。好吧，猜猜怎么着？什么？有有声读物。哦，天哪，哦，天哪，播放吧，萨姆，我想听听。好的，这是来自有声读物的片段
of Is Everyone Hanging Out Without Me and Other Concerns. It's published by Penguin Random House LLC and read by Mindy Kaling. I tend to fight with Greg the most. My friend and fellow Office writer Steve Healy believes it is because I am emotional and intuitive and Greg is more cerebral and logical. Or as I like to think of it, I am a sensitive poet and Greg is a mean robot. Our fighting is legendary.
《每个人都在没我的时候聚会吗？及其他担忧》。由企鹅兰登书屋有限责任公司出版，敏迪·卡灵朗读。我倾向于和格雷格吵架最多。我的朋友兼《办公室》编剧史蒂夫·希利认为这是因为我情绪化且直觉强，而格雷格更理智、更合乎逻辑。或者正如我喜欢想的那样，我是个敏感的诗人，而格雷格是个刻薄的机器人。我们的争吵是传奇性的。
One time, late at night, our script coordinator, Sean, and our head writer, Danny, both brought in their dogs. And upon seeing each other, they got into a violent barking fight. Paul Lieberstein glanced over and joked, I thought that was just Greg and Mindy. What do we fight about? I wish I could say there were big, smart, philosophical issues about writing or comedy, but sometimes they're as small as, if we do that cold open where Kevin dumps a tureen of chili on himself, I will quit the show.
有一次，深夜，我们的剧本协调员肖恩和我们的首席编剧丹尼都带了他们的狗来。一看到对方，它们就陷入了一场激烈的吠叫争吵。保罗·利伯斯坦瞥了一眼，开玩笑说，我还以为那是格雷格和敏迪呢。我们吵什么？我希望我能说是因为关于写作或喜剧的大而聪明的哲学问题，但有时它们小到，如果我们做那个凯文把一盆辣椒倒在自己身上的冷开场，我就辞职。
We did that cold open, by the way, and it was a hit, and I'm still working at the show. I can get a little theatrical, which makes sense because after all, I came up through the theater, said in my snootiest masterpiece theater voice. I will tell you about the worst fight we ever had. In a very heated rewrite session for the season three episode, Grief Counseling, I was arguing with Greg so much he finally said in front of all 12 writers, if you're gonna resist what I'm doing here, you can just go home, Mindy.
顺便说一句，我们做了那个冷开场，它很受欢迎，我还在节目组工作。我可以有点戏剧化，这说得通，因为毕竟，我是从剧院出来的，用我最势利的杰作剧院声音说道。我会告诉你我们发生过的最糟糕的争吵。在第三季《悲伤辅导》这一集的一次非常激烈的重写会议中，我和格雷格争论得太厉害了，他最终在所有12位编剧面前说，如果你要抵制我在这里做的事情，你可以直接回家，敏迪。
Greg never sends anyone home or even hints at it. Greg is the kind of guy who is so agreeable, I frequently find him on our studio lot embroiled in some long, boring conversation with a random person while his lunch is getting cold in his to-go container. And he's a boss. I would never talk to anyone if I was the boss. I would only talk to my attorney and my psychic. So anyway, my very nice boss had just hugely reprimanded me.
格雷格从不让任何人回家，甚至连暗示都没有。格雷格是那种非常随和的人，我经常发现他在我们的摄影棚里和某个随机的人进行着漫长而无聊的谈话，而他的午餐在他的外卖盒里变冷了。而且他还是个老板。如果我是老板，我绝不会和任何人说话。我只会和我的律师和我的通灵师说话。所以总之，我非常好的老板刚刚严厉地训斥了我。
Greg suggesting I go home unless I adjusted my attitude was the harshest he'd ever been to anyone in the three years I'd been on the show. There was silence. No one looked at me. People pretended to be absorbed in their phones. One writer didn't even have a phone, he just pretended to be absorbed in his hand. I was so embarrassed and angry that I got up, stomped out of the room, stole a 24 pack of bottled water
格雷格建议我回家，除非我调整态度，这是他在我加入节目的三年里对任何人最严厉的一次。一片寂静。没有人看我。人们假装沉浸在手机里。一个编剧甚至没有手机，他只是假装沉浸在自己的手里。我感到非常尴尬和愤怒，以至于我站起来，冲出房间，偷了一箱24瓶装的水
from the production office, kicked the bumper of Greg's car and left the studio. Is that amazing? It's amazing. I love the detail that she took a 24 pack of water. Oh yeah. She was like, oh, I'm leaving. I am leaving detail that she took a 24 pack of water. She was like, oh, I'm leaving. I am leaving.
从制作办公室拿走，踢了格雷格车的保险杠，离开了摄影棚。这不是很神奇吗？太神奇了。我喜欢她拿走一箱24瓶装水的细节。哦，是的。她当时想，哦，我要走了。我要走了。细节是她拿走了一箱水。她当时想，哦，我要走了。我要走了。
But I'm going to be hydrated. Well, listen, she goes on to say that after this, she went to a nail salon to get a pedicure. And the woman asked her, oh, do you have the day off? And Mindy was like, no, my boss threw me out of work. And the woman was like, oh, you got fired? And that's when Mindy was like, oh, wait, wait, what am I doing here?
但我会保持水分充足。好吧，听着，她接着说，在那之后，她去了一家美甲店做足疗。那个女人问她，哦，你今天休息吗？敏迪说，不，我老板把我赶出了工作岗位。那个女人说，哦，你被解雇了？就在那时，敏迪想，哦，等等，等等，我在做什么？
And she drove back to work and she told everyone she'd been in the bathroom, but Angela, she did keep that water. Good for you, Mindy. Her book is so fantastic. I own this book. It is hilarious. It is a great read.
然后她开车回到工作岗位，告诉大家她一直在洗手间，但安吉拉，她确实留下了那箱水。为你点赞，敏迪。她的书太棒了。我有这本书。它太搞笑了。这是一本很棒的书。
Mindy, thank you so much for letting us use a little excerpt from it. And you have to come on the show. And she is, guys, because I texted her. And she's coming on. Just wait. She's coming on. We won't say when, but it's happening.
敏迪，非常感谢你让我们使用其中的一小段摘录。你必须来参加我们的节目。她会的，伙计们，因为我给她发了短信。她要来了。等着吧。她要来了。我们不会说什么时候，但它会发生的。
It's soon. You guys, if you're looking for entertainment right now, give it a try. The audio book is available on the Penguin House audio website and soundcloud.com. And thank you to Penguin Random House for letting us play the clip. I love knowing that this was going on
很快。伙计们，如果你现在正在寻找娱乐，试一试吧。有声读物可以在企鹅兰登书屋音频网站和soundcloud.com上找到。感谢企鹅兰登书屋让我们播放这个片段。我喜欢知道这一切正在发生
in the backdrop of us filming this episode. You're kicking a car, you're taking water, Jen Salata's on set cracking up. What is happening in the writer's room? Should we move on to fast fact number three? I mean, I don't know how you beat one and two, but go for it. Well, I'm not sure I will,
在我们拍摄这一集的背景中。你在踢车，你在拿水，Jen Salata在片场笑场。编剧室里发生了什么？我们应该进入快讯第三条吗？我是说，我不知道你怎么能打败第一条和第二条，但尽管去做吧。好吧，我不确定我能，
but I got a little scoop from Kentopedia about this episode. Ooh! All right, on the first shoot day of this episode, Kent reminded me that we had our big season three photo shoot for NBC, where we did a big cast photo shoot, we did individual photos all in character, and since there weren't a lot of scenes happening in the break room, that's what we use for the photo shoot.
但我从Kentopedia那里得到了关于这一集的一点内幕。噢！好吧，在这一集的第一天拍摄日，肯特提醒我，我们有NBC的第三季大型照片拍摄，我们拍了一张大型演员合影，我们拍了所有角色的个人照片，由于休息室里没有发生很多场景，那就是我们用于照片拍摄的地方。
I don't know if you remember it, Angela. I do. They set up a desk, and then they would switch out the props on the desk, and we would take single photos. Yeah. And I have this very stern, single photo of me holding a pencil and a pad of paper with a drawing on it that I've never felt properly represents the character of Pam because I
我不知道你是否还记得，安吉拉。我记得。他们摆了一张桌子，然后他们会换掉桌子上的道具，我们会拍单人照。是的。我有一张非常严肃的单人照，我拿着一支铅笔和一个画着画的记事本，我从来不觉得这张照片能恰当地代表帕姆这个角色，因为我
think I look like a teacher who's ready to scold you in this photo as opposed to a woman going through a life-aling journey of love and expression. I have a photo of me looking very stern in a sort of a severe ponytail and I'm holding up a card with a cat on it. Well then they took the desks away and they loaded the break room with paper boxes and we all posed in front of them. Do you remember that one? I do because it was actually a very small space and when they got us all in there they
觉得在这张照片里我看起来像个准备训斥你的老师，而不是一个正在经历充满爱与表达的生命旅程的女人。我有一张照片，我看起来非常严肃，扎着一个严厉的马尾辫，手里举着一张画着猫的卡片。好吧，然后他们把桌子搬走了，他们在休息室里装满了纸箱，我们都站在它们前面摆姿势。你还记得那个吗？我记得，因为那实际上是一个非常小的空间，当他们把我们都弄进去时，他们
then couldn't figure out how to get us all in the photo. We were so jam-packed. So they had tiered these boxes like a little pyramid and guess who had to crawl up to the tippity top and is at the very top and really I just look like a very tiny floating head in the way back of the photo. It's me. Well, then they moved us all over to the warehouse. Do you remember this? And they made it rain paper on us.
然后就不知道怎么把我们都拍进照片里了。我们挤得满满当当。所以他们把这些箱子像小金字塔一样分层堆放，猜猜谁不得不爬到最顶端，就在最上面，真的，我看起来就像照片最远端的一个非常微小的漂浮脑袋。是我。好吧，然后他们把我们都搬到了仓库。你还记得这个吗？他们让我们在纸雨中。
They blew paper in a giant fan. This was a little insane because it took, I mean, I can't even remember how many times to blow the paper. Yeah, I have a great photo from this day. I don't know who took it actually, but it's in between whenever they blew the paper in the air, then they'd have to stop and reset it.
他们用巨大的风扇吹纸。这有点疯狂，因为它花了，我是说，我甚至不记得吹纸花了多少次。是的，我那天有一张很棒的照片。我不知道是谁拍的，实际上，但在他们把纸吹到空中之后，他们就得停下来重置它。
Yeah, they'd have to pick up all the paper from the ground. Yeah, and then someone would have to bring it back and toss it back in the air, right? So it was like a 20 minute turnaround between these setups. And in between the setups, we all had to just stay there in the warehouse. We're like on the loading dock area, right? Yeah.
是的，他们得把地上的纸都捡起来。是的，然后有人得把它带回来再扔回空中，对吧？所以这些设置之间有20分钟的周转时间。在设置之间，我们都得待在仓库里。我们就像在装卸区，对吧？是的。
And I'm in my skirt and my blouse, my severe ponytail, and I squat down, ladylike in a skirt. You know how you can tuck your skirt up in your leg and squat down so you're not ruining the mystery for anyone. Sure. You said sure like you weren't sure. I squat down in my Angela Martin outfit to talk to Paul Lieberstein. So there's this great photo of everyone sort of milling about in between this paper setup
我穿着裙子和衬衫，扎着严厉的马尾辫，我蹲下来，穿着裙子很淑女。你知道你怎么能把裙子塞进腿里蹲下来，这样你就不会破坏任何人的神秘感。当然。你说“当然”就像你不确定一样。我穿着我的安吉拉·马丁套装蹲下来和保罗·利伯斯坦说话。所以有一张很棒的照片，每个人都在这个纸设置之间闲逛
and I'm squatting down so completely out of character talking to Paul. I love it. Well, it was really crazy because we would have to shoot these whole episodes, but then also, like when they would be setting up a new scene, we would run off to the warehouse and take pictures with the paper coming down on us. Yeah, it was a bizarre day. It was super bizarre. And when Kent wrote me and reminded me of that, it all kind of came flooding back like,
而我蹲下来，完全脱离了角色，和保罗说话。我喜欢它。好吧，这真的很疯狂，因为我们必须拍摄这些完整的剧集，但同时，当他们设置新场景时，我们会跑到仓库，拍下纸落在我们身上的照片。是的，那是极其怪异的一天。超级怪异。当肯特写信提醒我时，这一切都涌上心头，就像，
oh yeah, remember how weird that was. Well, listen, should we take a break and then get into this episode? Let's do it. of that, it all kind of came flooding back like, oh yeah, remember how weird that was. Yeah. Well, listen, should we take a break and then get into this episode? Let's do it. Let's do it. All right, we'll be right back. ["The Big Main Room"]
哦，是的，记得那有多奇怪吗。好吧，听着，我们应该休息一下，然后进入这一集吗？我们开始吧。记得那有多奇怪吗。是的。好吧，听着，我们应该休息一下，然后进入这一集吗？我们开始吧。我们开始吧。好吧，我们马上回来。["The Big Main Room"]
All right, so we're back. We are in the bullpen. That's what we would call the big main room where, you know, Michael would always come out and talk to everyone. And he is doing a bit, guys. He has got a bit. He has stacked up some boxes of paper. Jenna, now that I remember that we were doing the photo shoot, I feel like those were the
好吧，我们回来了。我们在牛棚里。这就是我们称呼那个大主房间的地方，你知道，迈克尔总是会出来和大家说话。他在表演，伙计们。他有一个表演。他堆了一些纸箱。珍娜，现在我记得我们在拍照片，我觉得那些就是
boxes that were in the break room that we took pictures on. I'm not even kidding. They very may well have been. So Michael's doing that classic like stairs or escalator bit, you know, where you stack up a bunch of stuff and then you slowly just kind of crouch down. And Dwight thinks it is the funniest thing he's ever seen. Oh, Reign's reaction is like if you showed that to a five-year-old. Yeah. Yeah. Utter glee and just this is the best joke he's ever seen.
休息室里的箱子，我们在上面拍了照片。我一点也没开玩笑。它们很可能就是。所以迈克尔在做那种经典的楼梯或自动扶梯表演，你知道，你堆了一堆东西，然后你慢慢地蹲下来。德怀特认为这是他见过的最有趣的事情。哦，雷恩的反应就像你给一个五岁小孩看那个一样。是的。是的。纯粹的喜悦，这就是他见过的最好的笑话。
Ever seen. And also, he's laughing as if he's never heard of it. Yes, this is all new to him. He made it to be an adult man and has never seen the fake stairs bit. But I think in this episode, Pam is a little bit of the gem. Pam has taken on the jokester role, right? Yeah. So Ryan and Kevin joined in. They asked him to get little bit of the gym. Pam has taken on the jokester role, right? Yeah.
见过。而且，他笑得好像他从来没听说过它一样。是的，这一切对他来说都是新鲜的。他长成了一个成年男人，却从来没见过假楼梯表演。但我认为在这一集中，帕姆有点像宝石。帕姆扮演了爱开玩笑的角色，对吧？是的，所以瑞安和凯文加入了。他们让他拿一点点宝石，帕姆扮演了爱开玩笑的角色，对吧？是的。
So Ryan and Kevin joined in. They asked them to get little things like a pen, you know. But then Pam, showing a little bit of Pam's ass, is like, how about a cup of coffee? How about you give me a cup of coffee? And Michael's like, ehh. Well, I have a lot to say about this cold open, Ange. Oh, I want to hear it.
所以瑞安和凯文加入了。他们让他拿一些小东西，比如一支笔，你知道。但后来帕姆，展现了一点帕姆的个性，说，来杯咖啡怎么样？你给我来杯咖啡怎么样？迈克尔说，呃。好吧，关于这个冷开场，我有很多话要说，安吉。哦，我想听听。
First of all, this was not the original cold open in the script. Somebody has the original script. I've got a shooting draft of grief counseling. Let's hear it. The original cold open was in Stanford. Why? It involved a coworker of Jim wanting him to look at photos of her baby. Oh!
首先，这不是剧本里最初的冷开场。有人有原始剧本。我有一份《悲伤辅导》的拍摄草稿。让我们听听。最初的冷开场是在斯坦福。为什么？它涉及吉姆的一位同事想让他看她宝宝的照片。哦！
Oh, I saw this in a deleted scene! She gets really put out with him because she shows him a picture of her husband and the baby in the bathtub, and Jim finds it off-putting. He's like, oh god, they're in the bathtub. And she's like, oh, you know what? Come back to me when you have kids, okay? She gets really mad at them. Well, this was the original cold open.
哦，我在删除的场景里看到了这个！她对他很不满，因为她给他看了一张她丈夫和宝宝在浴缸里的照片，吉姆觉得这很反感。他说，哦天哪，他们在浴缸里。她说，哦，你知道吗？等你有了孩子再来找我，好吗？她对他们很生气。好吧，这就是最初的冷开场。
This cold open was added later and we shot it at the end of the week because it was an ad. And we had all those boxes. We had all those boxes from our photo shoot. Oh my gosh, I wonder if they were inspired. They were like, wait, I know what we can do with these boxes. We have all these boxes. We have all these boxes just stacked in the middle of the soundstage.
这个冷开场是后来加的，我们在周末结束时拍摄了它，因为它是一个广告。我们有所有那些箱子。我们有所有那些来自照片拍摄的箱子。天哪，我怀疑他们受到了启发。他们当时想，等等，我知道我们可以用这些箱子做什么。我们有所有这些箱子。我们有所有这些箱子就堆在摄影棚中间。
We got it. A lot of people wrote in and said, oh my gosh, how many takes did you guys do of this cold open? Because if you notice, Steve looks like he's like sweating when he brings Pam her coffee. He's sweating his butt off. He is so tired. Kent told me we did 10 takes. Oh no! 10 times. And every time we did a take, Steve went up and down the stairs three times. Oh my god, where's Steve? So he did that 30 times. He was getting like a major like, what are those like your quads? Says the person who never works out. What are those called?
我们做到了。很多人写信说，天哪，你们拍这个冷开场拍了多少次？因为如果你注意看，史蒂夫给帕姆拿咖啡时看起来像是在流汗。他汗流浃背。他太累了。肯特告诉我我们拍了10次。哦不！10次。每次我们拍的时候，史蒂夫都要上下楼梯三次。天哪，史蒂夫在哪？所以他做了30次。他得到了像，那些是什么，你的股四头肌？这是从不锻炼的人说的。那些叫什么？
Your quads. He was getting like his. There's probably some quad and glute. Quad and glute and then he had to crawl around. Any wonder poor guy. And Kent also told me that we actually did six different camera setups for the scene because they had to move the camera in different places to do the shot when he's crawling, when he goes inside the kitchen for his talking head, which is technically part of it. So yeah, but he walked up and down the stairs 30 times. Oh my gosh, Steve, your butt, it must have been so sore. Well, I have two little things in this opening scene.
你的股四头肌。他得到了他的。可能有一些股四头肌和臀大肌。股四头肌和臀大肌，然后他不得不爬来爬去。难怪可怜的家伙。肯特还告诉我，我们实际上为这个场景做了六种不同的摄像机设置，因为他们必须把摄像机移动到不同的地方来拍摄他爬行时的镜头，当他进入厨房进行他的谈话头镜头时，这在技术上是它的一部分。所以是的，但他上下楼梯30次。天哪，史蒂夫，你的屁股，一定很酸。好吧，在这个开场场景里我有两件小事。
First of all, at 51 seconds, I think Angela kind of smiles. Oh! When Pam says, get a cup of coffee, Angela kind of has a smile. Like there is a brief moment where I think she's on your side. I just wanted that to be documented. Oh, and then I have a great fan catch at one minute, 27 seconds. Ready for this? Yeah. Kelly and Chloe Harrigan and Shannon Rogowski, they wrote in and they noticed that when Michael returns from the kitchen when he's crawling on the ground, that that is Jim's coffee mug. That's the coffee mug that Jim always uses. Oh my gosh. Yes. Isn't that
首先，在51秒时，我觉得安吉拉笑了。哦！当帕姆说，拿杯咖啡时，安吉拉笑了。就像有一个短暂的时刻，我觉得她站在你这边。我只是想把它记录下来。哦，然后我在1分27秒有一个很棒的粉丝捕捉。准备好了吗？是的。凯利、克洛伊·哈里根和香农·罗加斯基，她们写信说，她们注意到当迈克尔从厨房回来，他在地上爬行时，那是吉姆的咖啡杯。那是吉姆总是用的咖啡杯。天哪。是的。这不是很
a great catch? And I was like, I wonder if that was a little nod to Jim so that Jim's presence got to be in Scranton for a little moment. I love that. Great catch, guys. Great catch. All right, so then we move into Michael's office, and he's on the phone with Jan, who informs him
一个很棒的捕捉吗？我当时想，我不知道这是否是对吉姆的一点致意，这样吉姆的存在就能在斯克兰顿停留片刻。我喜欢这个。捕捉得好，伙计们。捕捉得好。好吧，然后我们进入迈克尔的办公室，他在和简通电话，简通知他
that they have lost Ed Truck. And then Michael's like, well, I have his number somewhere. I can find it for you. Yeah. And she's like, no, Michael, Ed Truck has died. He goes out into the room. He breaks the news to everybody. Kelly rushes up, gives him a hug. Oh, we have a special appearance
他们失去了埃德·卡车。然后迈克尔说，好吧，我某处有他的号码。我可以为你找到它。是的。她说，不，迈克尔，埃德·卡车去世了。他走到房间里。他把这个消息告诉了大家。凯利冲过来，给了他一个拥抱。哦，我们有一个特别出场
by Kelly's extensions and her bangs. They make a special appearance. They are hugging Michael, giving him some comfort. And then Michael approaches Pam for a little awkward hug. So awkward. And lady, I have a track moment. I'm tracking it. I'm tracking it.
由凯利的接发和刘海。它们特别出场了。它们在拥抱迈克尔，给他一些安慰。然后迈克尔走近帕姆，进行了一个尴尬的拥抱。太尴尬了。而且女士，我有一个追踪时刻。我在追踪它。我在追踪它。
What are you tracking? You know I love to track the plants at front reception. Are there more new plants? Well, whatever happens to them, they make an appearance and then we never see them again. At three minutes, 29 seconds, I am pretty sure that's a succulent. We have a succulent. Succulent alert. Succulent alert at front reception.
你在追踪什么？你知道我喜欢追踪前台的植物。有更多新植物吗？好吧，无论它们发生了什么，它们出现了一次，然后我们就再也没见过它们。在3分29秒，我非常确定那是一株多肉植物。我们有一株多肉植物。多肉植物警报。前台多肉植物警报。
We'll probably never see it again. But when Michael hugs Pam awkwardly, you get a nice shot of that succulent. I'm not kidding. I really need to start a spreadsheet. I know, a really complex spreadsheet. All the things we're tracking. Well, next we move over to the Stanford office and a staff meeting becomes very awkward when Josh is super sexist and condescending to Karen.
我们可能再也见不到它了。但当迈克尔尴尬地拥抱帕姆时，你得到了那株多肉植物的漂亮镜头。我没开玩笑。我真的需要开始一个电子表格。我知道，一个非常复杂的电子表格。我们正在追踪的所有事情。好吧，接下来我们转到斯坦福办公室，一次员工会议变得非常尴尬，因为乔什对凯伦非常性别歧视和居高临下。
Oh, he was. He sort of just totally dismissed her. I know. Yeah, seriously. And then he puts Jim in charge of her for the day? Oh, gross. Oh my gosh. Is this just like, is this is like a physical representation
哦，他是。他只是完全无视了她。我知道。是的，说真的。然后他让吉姆负责她一天？哦，恶心。天哪。这只是，这就像是
of mansplaining, I feel like. Yeah. You know what? Jim, why don't you check in on that? Yeah, why don't you oversee that, Jim? Why don't you check in on that? And she's like, yeah, thanks. Yeah, thanks.
“男式说教”（mansplaining）的物理表现，我觉得。是的。你知道吗？吉姆，你为什么不检查一下那个？是的，你为什么不监督那个，吉姆？你为什么不检查一下那个？她说，是的，谢谢。是的，谢谢。
Yeah, thanks. Well, we had a fan catch from Brandon. He says, at 3 minutes and 42 seconds, when Karen is flipping through her stack of papers, I think I see a page from the script in her note. Oh oh that's such a good catch. You do. I froze it. Oh yeah she's got a little script page. We used to do that remember, Ange? We used to hide pages in our notebooks. I used to keep them in a drawer like in between takes. I would open my drawer and I would be like, okay, wait, did I get it? Did I get it to get it? And then I shut my
是的，谢谢。好吧，我们有一个来自布兰登的粉丝捕捉。他说，在3分42秒，当凯伦翻阅她的一叠纸时，我想我在她的笔记里看到了剧本的一页。哦，那真是个好捕捉。你确实看到了。我把它定格了。哦，是的，她有一小页剧本。我们过去常那样做，记得吗，安吉？我们过去常把页面藏在笔记本里。我过去常把它们放在抽屉里，比如在拍摄间隙。我会打开抽屉，我会想，好吧，等等，我拿到了吗？我拿到了吗？然后我关上我的
drawer again. Yes, we had scripts hidden everywhere on that set that we could just peek at between scenes to make sure we were like on our lines or if we wanted to like prep right before. I mean, obviously we had worked on them and we knew our lines. But when you're doing a bunch of takes, sometimes you're like, oh, oh wait crap, what was that? And you just want to do a quick peek. But also, you know, they would have their writer's draft and then we would read it at a table read and then they would make a bunch of changes and they would start on Monday with what was called the shooting draft.
抽屉。是的，我们在那个片场到处都藏着剧本，我们可以在场景之间偷看，以确保我们记住了台词，或者如果我们想在拍摄前准备一下。我是说，显然我们已经研究过它们，我们知道我们的台词。但当你拍很多次时，有时你会想，哦，哦等等该死，那是什么？你只是想快速看一眼。但同时，你知道，他们会有他们的编剧草稿，然后我们会在剧本朗读会上读它，然后他们会做很多修改，他们会在周一带着所谓的拍摄草稿开始。
And that's what I have. I have a bunch of shooting drafts left over. But every single morning we would arrive to work and there would be a stack of new pages. They were rewritten scenes just for that day. They would hand you the pages sometimes that morning and be like, OK, here we go, guys. These are your changes for the day. You better believe we were hiding pages
这就是我有的。我剩下了一堆拍摄草稿。但每天早上我们到达工作岗位时，都会有一叠新页面。它们是专门为那天重写的场景。他们有时会在那天早上把页面交给你，说，好的，我们开始吧，伙计们。这些是你们今天的修改。你最好相信我们在藏页面。
in our desks and notebooks. But yes, Brandon, you saw one. That just tickled me because that is so true. That was a good catch. OK, so now at four minutes, two seconds, Karen is really disappointed, you guys, because the chips that she likes, they're not in the vending machine.
在我们的办公桌和笔记本里。但是，布兰登，你确实看到了一个。这让我觉得很有趣，因为这太真实了。那真是个不错的发现。好了，现在时间到了四分零二秒，凯伦真的很失望，伙计们，因为她喜欢的薯片不在自动售货机里。
But I think Jim felt bad at the way Josh treated her, and he now wants to make amends, right? He wants to try to help her find these potato chips. And this whole scene about Karen and her potato chips just got me thinking about Rashida's breakfast order. Okay. Do you remember her breakfast order? No.
但我认为吉姆对乔什对待她的方式感到难过，他现在想弥补，对吧？他想试着帮她找到这些薯片。关于凯伦和她薯片的整个场景让我想到了拉什达的早餐订单。好吧。你还记得她的早餐订单吗？不记得。
Okay, well we often were in hair and makeup together at the same time. And I texted her, because I was like, Rashida, I totally just had this memory of your breakfast order. Here was the great thing about our caterer, Sergio. First of all, he was amazing. But if your order became kind of popular,
好吧，我们经常同时在化妆间。我给她发了短信，因为我想，拉什达，我完全想起了你的早餐订单。我们的餐饮服务商塞尔吉奥有一件很棒的事情。首先，他太棒了。但如果你的订单变得很受欢迎，
if other people liked it, you would get your name on the menu. So you would walk up to the truck to order breakfast in the morning, the food truck, and you could order a Rashida Angela size. Because I always wanted everything half portion because it was just big. The portions were big and I'm a little person, so I'd always say, can I have half of that? So they started calling it Angela size. So here's what the Rashida was. And Sergio, I ran into Sergio a while back
如果其他人也喜欢它，你的名字就会出现在菜单上。所以你早上走到餐车去点早餐时，那个餐车，你可以点一份“拉什达·安吉拉份”。因为我总是想要半份，因为分量太大了。分量很大，而我个子小，所以我总是说，我能要半份吗？所以他们开始叫它“安吉拉份”。这就是“拉什达”的内容。而且塞尔吉奥，我前阵子遇到了塞尔吉奥，
because I was working on a Netflix show and he was the caterer for it, for Mindy's show, Never Have I Ever. He was the caterer. Really? Yeah, Mindy hired him, which was fantastic. We had a little mini office reunion. And here's the Rashida, which you can still order from Sergio. Ready? Yes.
因为我当时在做一部Netflix的剧，他是那部剧的餐饮服务商，是明迪的剧《好想做一次》。他是餐饮服务商。真的吗？是的，明迪雇了他，这太棒了。我们有了一个小型的办公室重聚。这就是“拉什达”，你仍然可以从塞尔吉奥那里点到。准备好了吗？是的。
A corn tortilla, poached egg, black beans, avocado, turkey bacon, chalula on the side. And I was texting with Rashida about it and she was like, I don't even know how I functioned after eating that. Like why should I have just gone and taken a nap? But that's called the Rashida. And I can get that Angela size if I'm not that hungry. Yeah, I'd like the Rashida Angela size, please. Oh my gosh, that brought back so many memories. Molly Neck wrote in to say, guys, you can see her favorite chips in the vending machine slot B1. Okay, so there's a row of potato chips in the vending machine,
玉米饼、水煮蛋、黑豆、牛油果、火鸡培根，旁边配上Cholula辣酱。我和拉什达发短信聊到这个，她说，我甚至不知道吃完那个之后我是怎么工作的。就像我为什么不直接去小睡一会儿呢？但那叫“拉什达”。如果我不那么饿，我可以点那个“安吉拉份”。是的，请给我来一份“拉什达·安吉拉份”。天哪，这勾起了太多的回忆。莫莉·内克写信来说，伙计们，你们可以在自动售货机的B1槽位看到她最喜欢的薯片。好吧，自动售货机里有一排薯片，
but apparently those aren't the ones that Karen wants. Yes, Karen wants salt and vinegar potato chips. I did a mini deep dive on hers potato chips and Philadelphia Magazine did a ranking of all the vinegar potato chips, I did a mini deep dive on Hers potato chips. And Philadelphia Magazine did a ranking of all the Hers potato chips, and salt and vinegar was their number one chip. So it might make sense that it was hard to find because it's the number one chip. Close behind was Cheddar Horse Radish. Pam's favorite sour cream and onion was number four.
但显然那些不是凯伦想要的。是的，凯伦想要盐醋味薯片。我专门对Hers薯片做了一次小型深入研究，《费城杂志》对所有的醋味薯片进行了排名，我专门对Hers薯片做了一次小型深入研究。《费城杂志》对所有的Hers薯片进行了排名，盐醋味是他们排名第一的薯片。所以它很难找是有道理的，因为它是排名第一的薯片。紧随其后的是切达辣根味。帕姆最喜欢的酸奶油洋葱味排在第四。
Our favorite is their barbecue chips. I love their hers barbecue chips. I don't know where that is in the ranking. On the ranking? Okay. I'm sorry I didn't look that one up. Okay. But I do have a script catch for you as well. We're not done talking about this yet. In the shooting draft of the script, her favorite chips were going to be salsa verde Doritos. Wow. So here we go. We're going back to Scranton and Creed is in Michael's office with
我们最喜欢的是他们的烧烤味薯片。我喜欢他们的Hers烧烤味薯片。我不知道它在排名中的位置。在排名上？好吧。很抱歉我没查那个。好吧。但我也有一个剧本发现要告诉你。我们还没聊完这个。在剧本的拍摄草稿中，她最喜欢的薯片本来是莎莎酱味的多力多滋。哇。所以我们开始了。我们要回到斯克兰顿，克里德在迈克尔的办公室里，和
Dwight and Michael and he tells them that Ed was decapitated and Michael's like what? And he goes yeah he was flying down the road he'd been drinking and I guess he ran into a semi truck, right, and was decapitated. Angela, we got a lot of mail about this scene with Creed. OK, there is a very, very big debate online over whether or not Creed the character is making it up that Ed was decapitated or if it's the truth.
德怀特和迈克尔在一起，他告诉他们埃德被斩首了，迈克尔说，什么？他说，是的，他开车在路上飞驰，他喝了酒，我想他撞上了一辆半挂卡车，对吧，然后被斩首了。安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于克里德这个场景的邮件。好吧，网上有一个非常非常大的争论，关于克里德这个角色是在编造埃德被斩首的事，还是那是事实。
The truth within the show. And you know, Creed told some crazy stories, both on camera and off camera. So I can see where this sort of like controversy, if you will, around Creed's retelling of this is it true, is it not? Fiona, Danielle, Kelly, Danny, Mackenzie, Adam, and Valerie, they all said, how did Creed know the details of Ed Truck's death if Michael was the first
剧中的事实。你知道，克里德讲过一些疯狂的故事，无论是在镜头前还是镜头后。所以我能理解这种争议，如果你愿意的话，关于克里德对这件事的复述，它是真的吗，还是假的？菲奥娜、丹妮尔、凯利、丹尼、麦肯齐、亚当和瓦莱丽，他们都说，如果迈克尔是第一个
to know from corporate? So their theory is that Creed's making it up because there's no possible way for him to know more details than Michael. And then Maria pointed out that Creed lies later in another episode and says that Dwight was decapitated. That's in the episode, The Return. So she's like, maybe Creed is just obsessed with decapitation because he's a weird character. I don't know.
从公司得知消息的人，克里德是怎么知道埃德·卡车死亡细节的？所以他们的理论是克里德在编造，因为他不可能比迈克尔知道更多的细节。然后玛丽亚指出，克里德在另一集中撒谎说德怀特被斩首了。那是在《回归》那一集。所以她说，也许克里德只是痴迷于斩首，因为他是个古怪的角色。我不知道。
Well, here's the thing. I love that you guys were all writing back and forth about this. I think that because Creed knew Ed, he actually knew Ed, maybe there was someone he called, but we decided, hey, let's go to the source. Let's ask Jen Salata, was this story made up by Creed the character or was it truth
好吧，事情是这样的。我喜欢你们大家为此写来写去。我认为因为克里德认识埃德，他确实认识埃德，也许他给某人打了电话，但我们决定，嘿，让我们去找源头。让我们问问简·萨拉塔，这个故事是克里德这个角色编造的，还是事实
in the sort of scope of the show? Did this really happen? So here's what Jen had to say. Did Ed Truck really get decapitated? Sadly for Ed Truck, he did really get decapitated. It sounds like a Creed story, but it actually was a true story in the world of our show. There was no Ed Truck and he didn't really lose his head.
在剧集的范围内？这真的发生了吗？这就是简要说的。埃德·卡车真的被斩首了吗？对于埃德·卡车来说很遗憾，他确实被斩首了。这听起来像个克里德的故事，但它实际上是我们剧集世界里的一个真实故事。没有埃德·卡车这个人，他也没有真的丢掉脑袋。
However, in the world of The Office, he did get decapitated for real. I think it was Greg that came up with the decapitation. I can't quite remember and Greg can't remember, but I remember spending a lot of time talking about the way Michael's former boss would die and how it had to be something very sudden and jarring so that it could be a shock to Michael Scott's system,
然而，在《办公室》的世界里，他确实被斩首了。我想是格雷格想出了斩首这个点子。我不太记得了，格雷格也不记得了，但我记得花了很多时间讨论迈克尔的前老板会怎么死，而且必须是某种非常突然和令人震惊的事情，这样才能对迈克尔·斯科特的系统造成冲击，
that he could just freak out one day because he's just living his life and going into the office and then all of a sudden he could be dead. So I think that is where the decapitation came from. Unfortunately, I also can't remember who came up with his Kappa's detaited from his head. I feel like it wasn't me because I would have been really proud of it if it was me and I'd remember that.
这样他有一天可能会崩溃，因为他只是在过自己的生活，走进办公室，然后突然之间他就可能死了。所以我认为斩首就是从那里来的。不幸的是，我也记不起是谁想出了他的头被斩首这个点子。我觉得不是我，因为如果是我的话，我会为此感到非常自豪，而且我会记得的。
But yeah, the decapitation was real for Ed Truck. Sorry, Ed Truck. There you have it. Ed Truck really got decapitated. Creed actually got some facts that Michael didn't know. This is the slippery slope with Creed. And let me tell you, this is true in real life. And as his character, he'll say something and you're like,
但是的，斩首对埃德·卡车来说是真的。对不起，埃德·卡车。你得到了答案。埃德·卡车真的被斩首了。克里德确实得到了一些迈克尔不知道的事实。这就是克里德的滑坡效应。我告诉你，这在现实生活中也是真的。作为他的角色，他会说一些话，你会觉得，
that's not true. And then it's a hundred percent true. And then he'll say something else and it's total BS. So welcome to the world of Creed. That is true. And then he'll say something else, and it's total BS. So welcome to the world of Creed. That is true. Well, after this, Michael decides to break the news to the whole office. I love the little couplet.
那不是真的。然后它百分之百是真的。然后他会说别的话，那完全是胡扯。所以欢迎来到克里德的世界。那是真的。然后他会说别的话，那完全是胡扯。所以欢迎来到克里德的世界。那是真的。好吧，在这之后，迈克尔决定把这个消息告诉整个办公室。我喜欢那个小对句。
I just loved it. I watched it over and over of Michael being like, I don't know how to tell you this. And then Dwight is like, Ed Truck was decapitated. And he goes, what? And Michael's like, what are you doing? He's like, you said you didn't know how to say it. You said you didn't know how to say it.
我就是喜欢它。我一遍又一遍地看迈克尔说，我不知道该怎么告诉你们。然后德怀特说，埃德·卡车被斩首了。他说，什么？迈克尔说，你在干什么？他说，你说你不知道怎么说。你说你不知道怎么说。
Dwight is so literal, right? So literal, yeah. Oh my god. It made me laugh so hard, too. Well, lady, I want to talk about something in this scene, because at 5 minutes, 38 seconds, I wrote down Angela's face. What'd they do?
德怀特太死板了，对吧？太死板了，是的。天哪。这也让我笑得好厉害。好吧，女士，我想谈谈这个场景中的一些事情，因为在五分三十八秒，我记下了安吉拉的脸。他们做了什么？
I feel like in this moment, you have what I would consider to be a quintessential Angela reaction. You made so many sour faces on our show and they are so funny to me because I never see you make these faces in real life. They are so not your personality, but they have been turned into memes. You are known for this just disapproving look, but it's like, it's just funny to me
我觉得在这一刻，你有我认为是典型的安吉拉式反应。你在我们的节目中做了那么多酸溜溜的表情，它们对我来说太搞笑了，因为我在现实生活中从没见过你做这些表情。它们完全不是你的个性，但它们已经被做成了表情包。你以这种不赞成的表情而闻名，但这对我来说很有趣，
because in real life, you are nothing like this. You know, people write in and say, oh, you have resting bitch face. You've heard that expression, right? RBF. Yeah. But now they're just calling it resting Angela Martin face. It's like resting Angela face. I know.
因为在现实生活中，你一点也不像这样。你知道，人们写信来说，哦，你有“厌世脸”。你听过那个表达，对吧？RBF。是的。但现在他们只是叫它“安吉拉·马丁厌世脸”。就像“安吉拉厌世脸”。我知道。
But this is cracking me up right now, like in a whole different way because I am doing this show called Be Our Chef. You know, I'm hosting this family cooking competition. Lady, you know, I know this we watch it. We watch it religiously. My kids love this show. You guys it's a cooking show. It's on Disney Plus, you have to watch it. It's families cooking and competing. And Angela's the host, and it is just the sweetest, most uplifting,
但这让我现在笑得不行，因为我正在做这个叫《成为我们的厨师》的节目。你知道，我正在主持这个家庭烹饪比赛。女士，你知道，我知道这个，我们看了。我们虔诚地看它。我的孩子们喜欢这个节目。伙计们，这是一个烹饪节目。它在Disney Plus上，你们必须看。这是家庭烹饪和比赛。安吉拉是主持人，它真是最甜蜜、最令人振奋、
most just pure fun. Oh, that is so sweet. Here's the thing my family's doing. So you're saying that you froze on my face making the sour face? Yeah. My family keeps doing, like, freezing the screen when I'm making the weirdest faces.
最纯粹的乐趣。哦，那太甜了。事情是这样的，我的家人正在做。所以你是说你定格在我做那个酸溜溜表情的脸上了？是的。我的家人一直在做，比如，当我做最奇怪的表情时，定格屏幕。
I guess in Be Our Chef, I have learned that I talk really animated and I move my hands around and I, it's like I'm Jim Carrey. My kids think I look crazy most of the time on Be Our Chef. And their favorite thing now is to screen grab it and text me. I'm loving it.
我想在《成为我们的厨师》中，我学会了我说话非常生动，我挥动手臂，我，就像我是金·凯瑞。我的孩子们觉得我在《成为我们的厨师》里大部分时间看起来很疯狂。他们现在最喜欢的事情就是截屏并给我发短信。我喜欢它。
And Angela, I have to say this last Friday when it came on, I was like, guys, guys, we're gonna watch Be Our Chef. And Angela's it and Angela I have to say this last Friday when it came on I was like guys guys we're gonna watch BR Chef and Angela's on and my daughter goes you really love Angela. Oh she is your best friend and I said she is my best friend. Oh that is so sweet. I know. Okay so yes I make weird faces everybody I make weird faces. While we're talking about my weird faces Jenna in the scene where Dwight asked Angela to put his head on ice, right? Oh, yes. Okay. This is around five minutes 44 seconds right at the top of the scene I'm getting something out of the vending machine. Did you notice my jacket? Yeah, lady. I have the same timecode five minutes minutes, 44 seconds, I wrote, Angela Wardrobe,
安吉拉，我必须说，上周五它播出时，我说，伙计们，伙计们，我们要看《成为我们的厨师》。安吉拉在上面，我女儿说，你真的很喜欢安吉拉。哦，她是你的好朋友，我说她是我的好朋友。哦，那太甜了。我知道。好吧，所以是的，我做奇怪的表情，每个人，我做奇怪的表情。在我们谈论我奇怪的表情时，詹娜，在德怀特要求安吉拉把他的头放在冰上的那个场景，对吧？哦，是的。好吧。这大约在五分四十四秒，就在场景开始时，我正在从自动售货机里拿东西。你注意到我的夹克了吗？是的，女士。我有同样的时间码，五分四十四秒，我写道，安吉拉的服装，
what's up? What is up with your very odd short sleeved jacket? What is this item? It is a short, it's a pin. Can it be purchased or was this made for you? I think someone purchased it or found it in a warehouse like NBC, but it is a short sleeve pinstriped kind of like a dress jacket. And I jokingly called it to wardrobe my Janet Jackson jacket. Because do you remember I loved Janet Jackson and do you remember rhythm nation her album with the nation?
怎么了？你那件非常奇怪的短袖夹克是怎么回事？这是什么单品？它是一件短袖，它是一个别针。可以买到吗，还是为你做的？我想有人买了它，或者在像NBC这样的仓库里找到了它，但它是一件短袖条纹的，有点像礼服夹克。我开玩笑地称它为我的“珍妮·杰克逊夹克”。因为你还记得我喜欢珍妮·杰克逊吗，你还记得她的专辑《节奏国度》吗？
Okay, watch the music video of the song, All Right. She is wearing this pinstriped jacket. Course, mine was short sleeve. Hers was like regular, but we jokingly called this to the wardrobe department, my Janet Jackson jacket. I don't know, it was so weird. It was weird. It was like short sleeve, but it was a jacket.
好吧，看那首歌《All Right》的音乐录影带。她穿着这件条纹夹克。当然，我的是短袖的。她的是普通的，但我们开玩笑地称这件衣服为我的“珍妮·杰克逊夹克”。我不知道，它太奇怪了。它很奇怪。它就像短袖，但它是一件夹克。
I'm sorry to whoever designed it, but it's like your short sleeve blouse is peeking out underneath your short sleeve jacket It's an odd design. It's a total mess It's a total mess But it makes it makes me laugh to look back on it It a little bit reminds me of something that you might see on project runway when they had to like make a jacket out of another jacket, but it had to like make a jacket out of another jacket. But it had to not... Like they had to like reimagine the jacket.
我很抱歉设计它的人，但它看起来就像你的短袖衬衫从你的短袖夹克下面露出来。这是一个奇怪的设计。它完全是一团糟。它完全是一团糟。但回想起来让我发笑。它有点让我想起你在《天桥风云》中可能会看到的东西，当他们不得不像用另一件夹克做一件夹克时，但它不得不像重新构思那件夹克。
Reimagine the jacket and they just made it a short sleeve jacket and they were voted off. Yeah, pretty much. All right, guys. So then we have a pretty adorable Dwight Talkinghead where he says that he wants to be frozen when he dies, even if they have to do it in pieces. Even if he is decapitated, he wants to be frozen because he will wake up stronger than ever
重新构思那件夹克，他们只是把它做成了一件短袖夹克，然后他们就被投票淘汰了。是的，差不多。好了，伙计们。所以接下来我们有一个非常可爱的德怀特独白，他说他死后想被冷冻，即使他们必须把它分成几块。即使他被斩首了，他也想被冷冻，因为他醒来时会比以往任何时候都更强大，
and he will have been able to use that time to figure out how he died and how he could have better defended himself. Yeah, yeah, he's thought it through. He's thought it through. I love those talking heads. Angela does not wanna participate in this. Angela does not want to participate in this. She doesn't want to. No. So now Michael is on the phone with Jan and he really doesn't understand
他将能够利用那段时间弄清楚他是怎么死的，以及他本可以如何更好地保护自己。是的，是的，他考虑过了。他考虑过了。我喜欢那些独白。安吉拉不想参与这个。安吉拉不想参与这个。她不想。不。所以现在迈克尔在和简通电话，他真的不明白
why they have a day honoring Martin Luther King when he didn't even work at Dunder Mifflin. Yeah, but Ed Truck, Ed Truck sat at his same desk and has died and Jan's, OK, listen, do you want to just give everyone the day off? And he's like, you don't get these people. They wouldn't want that. No, they don't want to go home. What they want is a robot statue of Ed Truck. The eyes light up. Yeah.
为什么他们要有一天纪念马丁·路德·金，而他甚至不在邓德·米夫林工作。是的，但埃德·卡车，埃德·卡车坐在他同一个办公桌上，已经死了，简说，好吧，听着，你想给每个人放一天假吗？他说，你不了解这些人。他们不会想要那样的。不，他们不想回家。他们想要的是一个埃德·卡车的机器人雕像。眼睛会发光。是的。
That's what they want. Well, we had a fan question here from Sierra. When Michael is on the phone with Jan and has an article with a picture of himself and Ed on the desk in front of him, he slowly drags the corner of an envelope down to cover Ed's head, you know, because he'd been decapitated. Was that scripted? Yes, that action was scripted. It was in the script. And then, of course, you see they made, the camera made sure to capture it.
那就是他们想要的。好吧，我们这里有一个来自塞拉的粉丝问题。当迈克尔和简通电话，桌上放着一张他和埃德的照片时，他慢慢地拖动信封的一角盖住埃德的头，你知道，因为他被斩首了。那是剧本写的吗？是的，那个动作是剧本写的。它在剧本里。然后，当然，你看到他们拍了，摄像机确保捕捉到了它。
So smart. So smart. So thought out. Well, I really thought Dwight's drawing of the robot with the six foot extension cord to the wall so it couldn't attack him. I thought that was fantastic. And I wanted to know who drew it,
太聪明了。太聪明了。太深思熟虑了。好吧，我真的认为德怀特画的那个带着六英尺延长线连到墙上的机器人，这样它就不能攻击他了。我觉得那太棒了。我想知道是谁画的，
but we probably don't know, do we? We don't know. We had fan questions about that too, Ange, and I tried to find out, but I couldn't get the answer for you. I'm sorry. That's all right. I don't know, do we? We don't know. We had fan questions about that too, Ange, and I tried to find out, but I couldn't get the answer for you, I'm sorry. That's all right. I feel like Phil Shea drew it in the back just quickly on a notepad.
但我们可能不知道，对吧？我们不知道。我们也有关于那个的粉丝问题，安吉，我试着查了一下，但我没能为你找到答案。我很抱歉。没关系。我不知道，对吧？我们不知道。我们也有关于那个的粉丝问题，安吉，我试着查了一下，但我没能为你找到答案，我很抱歉。没关系。我觉得是菲尔·谢在后面匆忙在记事本上画的。
I'm sure. But I feel like I can say with 99% certainty, it was not rain. I feel like rain might've doodled on it during the scene, but the original drawing was not Rain. Yes. Okay, now we have to go back over to Stanford. I actually texted Ed Helms. I said, Ed, you just made me do the snort laugh so hard because here we are, Jim and Karen are still trying to find these chips.
我肯定。但我可以以99%的把握说，那不是雷恩画的。我觉得雷恩可能在场景中涂鸦过，但最初的画不是雷恩画的。是的。好吧，现在我们必须回到斯坦福。我实际上给埃德·赫尔姆斯发了短信。我说，埃德，你刚才让我笑得好厉害，因为我们在这里，吉姆和凯伦还在试图找到这些薯片。
They're having a hard time, but Jim's like, we're not going to quit. And she's like, I'm not a quitter. And then Andy's like, what's the game? What are we playing? I'm in. And then they tell him, we can't find the chips. And he's like, did you check the vending machine? They're like, oh, no. Actually, we checked the fax machine.
他们遇到了困难，但吉姆说，我们不会放弃。她说，我不是一个放弃者。然后安迪说，什么游戏？我们在玩什么？我加入。然后他们告诉他，我们找不到薯片。他说，你们检查过自动售货机了吗？他们说，哦，不。实际上，我们检查了传真机。
And you see how pissed off Andy gets at them. Because he knows. He knows they're being smartasses. And he just looks at them so seriously and goes did you check your butt? It made me laugh so hard. I like watched it twice back to back so I was like oh my god and then I texted Ed I said Ed you are so funny in this scene I texted him the line and he was like we were like
你看到安迪对他们有多生气了。因为他知道。他知道他们在装聪明。他非常严肃地看着他们说，你们检查过你们的屁股了吗？这让我笑得好厉害。我像连续看了两次，所以我当时想，天哪，然后我给埃德发了短信，我说埃德，你在这个场景里太搞笑了，我给他发了那句台词，他说我们就像
trading texts about it just cracking up. Well that line is in the script. I went and looked. I had to know. But I don't know if you noticed in this scene, seven minutes, 35 seconds, the smile post-it is gone from Jim's computer. You've been tracking that post-it, lady.
交换短信聊这个，笑得不行。好吧，那句台词在剧本里。我去看了。我必须知道。但我不知道你有没有注意到这个场景，七分三十五秒，那个笑脸便利贴从吉姆的电脑上消失了。你一直在追踪那个便利贴，女士。
I've been tracking it. Gone. And I don't know if you notice, I mean, he's acting more like Jim now, right? Like he's got a little thing, he's dazzling a lady with his charm. He's getting more comfortable. Yeah, he's more comfortable and he has an adventure within work, right? That's kind of like, this is a boring job to Jim, so he always has to find a distraction to get him through the day. Jim's the guy who makes work more fun, right,
我一直在追踪它。不见了。我不知道你有没有注意到，我的意思是，他现在表现得更像吉姆了，对吧？就像他有了一点小动作，他用他的魅力让一位女士眼花缭乱。他变得更自在了。是的，他更自在了，他在工作中也有了冒险，对吧？这有点像，这对吉姆来说是一份无聊的工作，所以他总是必须找到一种消遣来度过这一天。吉姆是那个让工作变得更有趣的人，对吧，
with his little things like this that he does. So he's back to his old ways. Back at the Scranton branch, Michael is just obsessed now. He just can't stop thinking about Ed Truck, and he's really starting to internalize it about himself, right? Like, what if I were gone? No one cares here.
用他做的这些小事。所以他回到了他的老路子。回到斯克兰顿分部，迈克尔现在简直着了魔。他就是无法停止思考埃德·卡车，他真的开始把它内化到自己身上了，对吧？就像，如果我走了怎么办？这里没人关心。
No one cares. And he decides that they probably need some grief counseling. They're in denial. Yeah. Yeah, he wants us to know the stages of grief. And he feels like it's his job to take us through them. He doesn't know if he can get us all the way to acceptance. But if he can get us depressed, he will have done his job to take us through them. He doesn't know if he can get us all the way to acceptance,
没人关心。他决定他们可能需要一些悲伤辅导。他们处于否认状态。是的。是的，他想让我们知道悲伤的阶段。他觉得带我们经历这些是他的工作。他不知道他是否能带我们一直走到接受。但如果他能让我们感到沮丧，他就完成了他的工作。带我们经历这些。他不知道他是否能带我们一直走到接受，
but if he can get us depressed, he will have done his job. It's such a great line. It's such a good line. I have a really great little tidbit right here. What is it? Okay. So in the deleted scenes, Toby is actually a trained grief counselor. Okay. Yes. and so, you know, Dwight's like, Toby should probably lead us through this. He's a trained grief counselor. And Toby starts to walk them through the steps. They're in the conference room. And Michael's like, oh, you're ruining everything.
但如果他能让我们感到沮丧，他就完成了他的工作。这真是一句很棒的台词。这真是一句好台词。我这里有一个非常棒的小花絮。是什么？好吧。所以在删除的场景中，托比实际上是一名受过训练的悲伤辅导员。好吧。是的，所以，你知道，德怀特说，托比可能应该带领我们经历这个。他是一名受过训练的悲伤辅导员。托比开始引导他们经历这些步骤。他们在会议室里。迈克尔说，哦，你把一切都毁了。
It's gonna take me forever to undo what you've done. And of course, Toby was being perfectly normal and appropriate, right? Yes. Michael's like, you you're ruining it and this whole scene is in the conference room taking place around the conference table. Everyone's sitting there and Michael's like that's it I'm gonna have to fix everything you've ruined Toby. Ryan, Dwight take the conference table out we're gonna take a five-minute break while they reset and we're coming back in here and I'm going to lead you in grief counseling. And I about fell out of my chair because in my knowledge that is the first time we have
我得花很长时间才能撤销你所做的一切。当然，托比表现得非常正常和得体，对吧？是的。迈克尔说，你，你毁了它，整个场景都在会议室里，在会议桌旁进行。每个人都坐在那里，迈克尔说，就是这样，我得修复你毁掉的一切，托比。瑞安，德怀特，把会议桌搬走，我们要休息五分钟，等他们重置，我们再回来，我要带领你们进行悲伤辅导。我差点从椅子上掉下来，因为据我所知，这是我们第一次
ever referenced the dang conference table. Oh my gosh and now we know who's always moving it. It's Dwight and Ryan. Dwight and Ryan. Where they put it? I don't know. We don't know. It was the first time I ever heard Michael say, okay, let's get the conference table out of here.
引用了那张该死的会议桌。天哪，现在我们知道是谁一直在搬它了。是德怀特和瑞安。德怀特和瑞安。他们把它放哪了？我不知道。我们不知道。这是我第一次听到迈克尔说，好吧，把会议桌搬出去。
Yes, acknowledging that the conference table can be removed and replaced. On a whim. How do they get it out of the doorway? I don't know, they probably have to take it apart, but Michael's like, we're gonna take five to 10 minute break, and when we get back in here, we're going to get down to it.
是的，承认会议桌可以被移除和更换。心血来潮。他们是怎么把它从门口弄出去的？我不知道，他们可能得把它拆开，但迈克尔说，我们要休息五到十分钟，当我们回来时，我们要开始工作了。
And then the next scene is them with the little ball that they're about to toss around. But that's a deleted scene that sets it up. I love that. I love that. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we will meet Michael in the conference room for some of his grief counseling. Yeah, and maybe... Sound good? Maybe Roy will stop by. Who knows? He might. will meet Michael in the conference room for some of his grief counseling. Yeah, and maybe...
然后下一个场景是他们拿着那个他们准备扔来扔去的小球。但那是一个设置它的删除场景。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？然后当我们回来时，我们将在会议室里见到迈克尔进行他的一些悲伤辅导。是的，也许……听起来不错？也许罗伊会顺便过来。谁知道呢？他可能会。见到迈克尔在会议室里进行他的一些悲伤辅导。是的，也许……
Sound good? Maybe Roy will stop by. Who knows? He might. Mm-hmm. Because Pam might need a little break as well. All right. All right.
听起来不错？也许罗伊会顺便过来。谁知道呢？他可能会。嗯哼。因为帕姆可能也需要一点休息。好吧。好吧。
We'll be right back. Spring is here, and you can now get almost anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? I mean, you can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can now get almost anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? You can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can get chicken parmesan delivered. Sunshine? No. Some wine? Yes. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats.
我们马上回来。春天到了，你现在可以用Uber Eats送达几乎任何你需要的东西。我们说的“几乎”是什么意思？我的意思是，你不能送达一片修剪整齐的草坪，但你现在可以用Uber Eats送达几乎任何你需要的东西。我们说的“几乎”是什么意思？你不能送达一片修剪整齐的草坪，但你可以送达鸡肉帕尔马干酪。阳光？不。一些葡萄酒？是的。用Uber Eats送达几乎，几乎任何东西。
Order now. Alcohol in select markets. See app for details. And we're back. Here we are. Angela, what did you do during the break? I went and got an iced tea, Jenna, and I said hi to my husband, and I walked up, I guess, behind him kind of quietly, and I scared the crap out of him. Oh, boy. That's what I did on my break. I was like, hey, he was like, ah! Why does it get me so tickled? I like, I don't know why spooking him makes me laugh so hard. I got a cup of coffee, and then I put the sheets from the washer
现在下单。酒精在特定市场。详情请见应用程序。我们回来了。我们在这里。安吉拉，休息期间你做了什么？我去拿了冰茶，詹娜，我跟我丈夫打了招呼，我想我悄悄地走到他身后，把他吓了一跳。哦，天哪。这就是我在休息时做的。我当时说，嘿，他当时说，啊！为什么这让我觉得这么有趣？我喜欢，我不知道为什么吓他让我笑得这么厉害。我拿了一杯咖啡，然后我把洗衣机里的床单
into the dryer. And I'm all excited that I'm podcasting and doing the laundry at the same time, because you know I love a good multitasking. Oh, yeah. Oh, I have laundry going, lady. I started in the morning. Oh, it's going.
放进了烘干机。我很高兴我一边做播客一边洗衣服，因为你知道我喜欢一心多用。哦，是的。哦，我有衣服在洗，女士。我早上就开始了。哦，它在运行。
Also, I find that when I do laundry, I can't podcast in my closet, because you can hear the dryer. So on the days I do laundry, I podcast in my shed. There you go. There you go. Making it work, podcasting from home. I'm in my pajamas.
另外，我发现当我洗衣服时，我不能在衣柜里做播客，因为你能听到烘干机的声音。所以在我洗衣服的日子里，我在棚子里做播客。就是这样。就是这样。让它工作，在家做播客。我穿着睡衣。
I never said that at the beginning. Oh, I noticed. I just didn't get dressed. I didn't say anything, but I noticed. I did my hair, though. I don't know what that says about me. When my hair is done, I feel good, even if I'm still in my pajamas. There you go.
我一开始没说。哦，我注意到了。我只是没穿衣服。我什么也没说，但我注意到了。不过我做了头发。我不知道这说明我什么。当我的头发做好时，我感觉很好，即使我还在穿睡衣。就是这样。
All right, guys. We are back in the conference room, and Michael is going to lead us in some grief exercises. It involves taking a ball. And when you have the ball, you can talk about a moment of grief in your life. Michael goes first. Of course. Michael goes first. And he talks about Ed Truck.
好吧，伙计们。我们回到了会议室，迈克尔将带领我们进行一些悲伤练习。它涉及拿一个球。当你拿着球时，你可以谈论你生命中的一个悲伤时刻。迈克尔先来。当然。迈克尔先来。他谈到了埃德·卡车。
Angela, when he says his feelings about Ed Truck, it's so good. He goes on and on. I asked Sam to pull a clip so that we could all listen to it together. Oh, god. I'm so happy about this, because I wrote in my journal that in this scene, this particular moment,
安吉拉，当他说出他对埃德·卡车的感受时，太棒了。他没完没了。我让萨姆剪了一个片段，这样我们就可以一起听了。哦，天哪。我对此很高兴，因为我在日记里写道，在这个场景中，这一刻，
we could not get through. And lady, it's not in the script. This was, I think, an improvisation by Steve. Oh my god. Okay, well there's one line. I'm not gonna say it yet. Let's listen to it. There's one line that I wrote in my journal. We all disintegrated. Mom! Oh my god, wait. Hold on. What is it, baby? Sunny got a bird.
我们无法坚持下去。女士，剧本里没有。我想这是史蒂夫的即兴创作。哦，天哪。好吧，有一句台词。我还没打算说。让我们听听。我日记里写了一句台词。我们都崩溃了。妈妈！哦，天哪，等等。等等。怎么了，宝贝？桑尼抓到了一只鸟。
Oh, f***. Okay, hold on. I'll be right back. Okay. He got one of the doves. Yeah. And what's happening? Got a bird. Sunny is their cat.
哦，该死。好吧，等等。我马上回来。好吧。他抓到了其中一只鸽子。是的。发生了什么？抓到了一只鸟。桑尼是他们的猫。
So here's the thing. This podcast started with me telling about a squirrel that ate a bird and now their cat just got a bird. I'm telling you, this is the bird funeral podcast. Okay, okay. I'm so sorry. I'm back. What happened then? What happened? You guys, we got a grocery delivery and Sunny shot out the door and I guess caught a bird,
所以事情是这样的。这个播客开始时我讲了一只吃鸟的松鼠，现在他们的猫刚抓到了一只鸟。我告诉你，这是“鸟类葬礼”播客。好吧，好吧。我很抱歉。我回来了。然后发生了什么？发生了什么？伙计们，我们收到了杂货配送，桑尼冲出门外，我想抓到了一只鸟，
right? This is so insane that we're doing this episode right now. And Angela, you had a squirrel eating your bird when you were prepping. I had a squirrel eating your bird when you were prepping. I had a squirrel eating a bird. Now your cat has like attacked a bird. Okay, but listen, it's good news. I have good news. We caught Sunny. We wrestled him to the ground. We got the bird out of his mouth and it's a pretty big bird and he was unharmed. The bird was unharmed. You saved the bird.
对吧？我们现在做这一集真是太疯狂了。安吉拉，你准备的时候有一只松鼠在吃你的鸟。我准备的时候有一只松鼠在吃你的鸟。我有一只松鼠在吃一只鸟。现在你的猫攻击了一只鸟。好吧，但听着，这是好消息。我有好消息。我们抓住了桑尼。我们把他摔倒在地。我们从他嘴里把鸟拿了出来，那是一只相当大的鸟，他没有受伤。鸟没有受伤。你救了那只鸟。
The bird's okay. Michael would be so happy. What's gonna happen next week for the initiation? I don't know, I don't know. I don't wanna be initiated, Jenna. No. I don't want it. Oh, please. Don't bring that over here. I don't want any of that.
鸟没事。迈克尔会很高兴的。下周入会仪式会发生什么？我不知道，我不知道。我不想入会，詹娜。不。我不想要它。哦，拜托。别把那个带到这里来。我不想要任何那种东西。
Okay. All right, well, that was crazy. And- So sorry. I can't believe this is all happening in grief counseling, but let's, okay, where were we? All right. Well, that was crazy. And so sorry, I can't believe this is all happening in grief counseling. But let's OK, where were we? All right. Let's play this clip of Michael talking about his grief of Ed Truck. I lost a truck and it feels like somebody took my heart
好吧。好吧，那太疯狂了。而且——很抱歉。我不敢相信这一切都发生在悲伤辅导中，但让我们，好吧，我们刚才说到哪了？好吧。好吧，那太疯狂了。而且很抱歉，我不敢相信这一切都发生在悲伤辅导中。但让我们，好吧，我们刚才说到哪了？好吧。让我们播放迈克尔谈论他为埃德·卡车悲伤的片段。我失去了一辆卡车，感觉就像有人拿走了我的心
and dropped it into a bucket of boiling tears. And at the same time, somebody else is hitting my soul in the crotch with a frozen sledgehammer and then a third guy walks in and starts punching me in the grief bone and I'm crying and nobody can hear me because I am terribly, terribly, terribly alone. Angela, can I guess the line that we couldn't get through? Yeah. Is it frozen sledgehammer? Wait, I put every one of us broke when he said
把它扔进了一桶沸腾的眼泪里。与此同时，另一个人正用一把冷冻的大锤击打我的灵魂裆部，然后第三个人走进来，开始猛击我的悲伤骨，我在哭，没人能听到我，因为我非常、非常、非常孤独。安吉拉，我能猜出我们无法坚持下去的那句台词吗？是的。是冷冻大锤吗？等等，我写道，当他说
that his soul was getting hit in the crotch with a frozen sledgehammer. Yes, yes. That's what I wrote in my journal. I said we could not keep it together. Okay, I said that's not in the script. I don't know if he was handed that rewrite on the day, but it feels like that's a Steve improv. That feels like Steve to me. Oh man, man, man. That got us good though. Oh man.
他的灵魂被冷冻大锤击中裆部时，我们每个人都崩溃了。是的，是的。这就是我在日记里写的。我说我们无法保持冷静。好吧，我说那不在剧本里。我不知道他那天是否收到了那个重写，但感觉那是史蒂夫的即兴创作。那感觉像是史蒂夫。哦，伙计，伙计，伙计。那确实让我们笑得很好。哦，伙计。
That is us good though. Oh man. That is so good. Well then, Roy walks in. There's a problem with Pam's car. Can she come down to the parking lot and take a look at it? Oh yeah. So there is an extended scene of this in the deleted scenes. So if you thought it was awkward enough, their conversation by the car, there's, it's extended
那确实让我们笑得很好。哦，伙计。那太棒了。然后，罗伊走了进来。帕姆的车出了问题。她能下到停车场去看看吗？哦，是的。所以删除的场景中有一个关于这个的扩展场景。所以如果你觉得他们的车边对话已经够尴尬了，还有，它是扩展的
and even more awkward. Jenna, here's my question for you. How did Roy know that she was stuck in the conference room? How? How did he know there was grief counseling? How? Oh, okay. I think you're implying that she called Roy and told him about it. I'm just saying, how did he know? How did he know?
而且更尴尬。詹娜，这是我给你的问题。罗伊怎么知道她被困在会议室里了？怎么知道的？他怎么知道有悲伤辅导？怎么知道的？哦，好吧。我想你在暗示她给罗伊打了电话告诉他这件事。我只是说，他怎么知道的？他怎么知道的？
Okay, I have a take on it. I think Michael called Daryl down in the warehouse and said, bring everyone up for some grief counseling, and Daryl was like, no. No. Well, that would explain it. Yes, that would explain it. We had a fan question from Alexa Porter.
好吧，我有我的看法。我想迈克尔给仓库里的达里尔打了电话说，把每个人都带上来进行悲伤辅导，达里尔说，不。不。好吧，那就能解释了。是的，那就能解释了。我们有一个来自亚历克萨·波特的粉丝问题。
Was there ever talk of putting Pam and Roy back together or was it all just a setup to mess with our feelings? Well, there was talk in the writers room that maybe Roy could win Pam back. Remember David Denman was made a series regular for season three. Yeah. So he's gonna be making a lot of appearances this season. I can tell you guys, nothing was decided at this point about what would happen with Jim and Pam, what would happen with Pam and Roy. They were feeling it out week to week.
有没有谈过让帕姆和罗伊复合，还是这一切只是为了戏弄我们的感情？好吧，编剧室里确实讨论过也许罗伊能赢回帕姆。记得大卫·丹曼在第三季被定为常规演员吗？是的。所以他这一季会经常出现。我可以告诉你们，当时关于吉姆和帕姆会发生什么，帕姆和罗伊会发生什么，还没有决定。他们每周都在感受。
I totally remember that. I also remember it was constantly said that maybe, maybe in this series of The Office, Jim and Pam would not end up together in the end, but would instead lead one another to their actual true loves. It had not been decided right now that Jim and Pam were one another's true loves. When you just said that, I got angry. Oh no.
我完全记得那个。我还记得经常有人说，也许，也许在《办公室》这个系列中，吉姆和帕姆最终不会在一起，而是会引导彼此找到他们真正的真爱。当时还没有决定吉姆和帕姆是彼此的真爱。当你刚才说那句话时，我生气了。哦，不。
I was like, no, Jim and Pam end up together. No. Ugh. Well, I think maybe that's why the writing of their characters felt so authentic, because the writers were figuring out their relationship at the same time that Jim and Pam were. Yeah, so we're, as an audience, we feel that, like, what will happen? We don't know. These are two people on journeys trying to find themselves themselves and hopefully that leads them back to each other. Mm hmm. Exactly.
我当时想，不，吉姆和帕姆最终在一起。不。呃。好吧，我想也许这就是为什么他们角色的写作感觉如此真实，因为编剧们在吉姆和帕姆弄清楚他们的关系的同时也在弄清楚。是的，所以，作为观众，我们感受到了，就像，会发生什么？我们不知道。这是两个在旅途中的人，试图找到他们自己，希望这能引导他们回到彼此身边。嗯哼。正是如此。
All right. So while Pam and Roy are out in the parking lot, I'm sure Pam was really hoping that she's going to come back to the like conference room and the grief counseling is almost over. But no, they waited for her because they're a family. I love that detail. They waited for her. Yes. There's a great scene on the DVD. It's a deleted scene and Michael is trying to get everyone to loosen up, right? For the grief counseling, he's like, hey guys, take your jackets off, loosen your ties, take off your shoes, ladies, let your hair down. And Angela goes, I don't think Kevin should take off his shoes.
好吧。所以当帕姆和罗伊在停车场时，我相信帕姆真的希望她能回到会议室，悲伤辅导快结束了。但没有，他们等了她，因为他们是一家人。我喜欢那个细节。他们等了她。是的。DVD上有一个很棒的场景。这是一个删除的场景，迈克尔正试图让每个人放松，对吧？为了悲伤辅导，他说，嘿伙计们，脱掉你们的夹克，松开你们的领带，脱掉你们的鞋子，女士们，放下你们的头发。安吉拉说，我不认为凯文应该脱掉他的鞋子。
I don't think Kevin should take off his shoes. Oh, and Kevin gets really annoyed. And then he has a talking head that he says, all right, listen, I have hyperhidrosis, okay? So we find out that he has this disease that makes your feet sweat really, really badly. So I guess he's been taking his shoes off over an accounting. I love this little tidbit, and I'm sad it didn't make it in. Well, this explains why when Pam walks into the room,
我不认为凯文应该脱掉他的鞋子。哦，凯文变得非常恼火。然后他有一个独白，他说，好吧，听着，我有汗疱疹，好吗？所以我们发现他有这种让你的脚出汗非常严重的疾病。所以我猜他一直在会计部脱鞋。我喜欢这个小花絮，我很遗憾它没能放进去。好吧，这就解释了为什么当帕姆走进房间时，
Kevin's feet are up on her chair and his shoes are off. Yes, people wrote in and asked about that. It's because in the deleted scene, Michael's getting everyone to loosen up, and we find out that Kevin has, how do you say it? Hyperhidrosis. Angela, I love that. That's a good catch.
凯文的脚放在她的椅子上，他的鞋子脱了。是的，人们写信问过那个。这是因为在删除的场景中，迈克尔让每个人放松，我们发现凯文有，你怎么说？汗疱疹。安吉拉，我喜欢那个。那是个不错的发现。
That's a good catch. Good tip. Tidbit. Tidbit. It's a Kinsey tidbit. All right. So when Pam does finally get back, they begin again and Dwight is the first one to share. Oh, this is one of my favorite things.
那是个不错的发现。好花絮。花絮。这是一个金西花絮。好吧。所以当帕姆终于回来时，他们重新开始，德怀特是第一个分享的。哦，这是我最喜欢的事情之一。
And Dwight shares that he was supposed to have a twin, but he absorbed the twin in utero. All right, we had a fan question from Aira Tajali. Did Rainn Wilson make the whole absorbing twin thing up, or was it scripted? Well, first of all, I will tell you it is not in the script. I don't know if Rain made it up, but in the script Dwight was supposed to say this. He was supposed to say, in the blizzard of 97, 12 shrewds died in the
德怀特分享说他本该有一个双胞胎，但他还在子宫里就吸收了那个双胞胎。好吧，我们有一个来自艾拉·塔贾利的粉丝问题。雷恩·威尔逊是编造了吸收双胞胎的事情，还是剧本写的？好吧，首先，我会告诉你它不在剧本里。我不知道雷恩是否编造了它，但在剧本中德怀特本该说这个。他本该说，在97年的暴风雪中，12只鼩鼱死在了
basement of our house. They drank beer cider that had already turned. President McKinley declared it a national emergency. Now my favorite thing about that is that clearly it's not 1997. It's like 1897. Yeah, yeah. I guess. But that was originally Dwight's grief share. So here's the thing.
我们房子的地下室里。它们喝了已经变质的啤酒苹果酒。麦金莱总统宣布这为国家紧急状态。现在我最喜欢的是，显然那不是1997年。那是1897年。是的，是的。我猜。但那最初是德怀特的悲伤分享。所以事情是这样的。
I reached out to Jen Salata about this. And this is maybe one of my favorite text threads of all time. This is what tickled me so much is that Jen Salata, Jenna, she's one of our people. She's a deep diver. The minute I asked her, she went on a deep dive for the whole afternoon.
我联系了简·萨拉塔关于这个。这可能是我有史以来最喜欢的短信串之一。这让我觉得很有趣的是，简·萨拉塔，詹娜，她是我们的伙伴之一。她是一个深入挖掘者。我一问她，她整个下午都在深入挖掘。
Ready? So I say, OK, Jen, Dwight's speech about absorbing his twin is not in the script. Was that an improv? Did you tell him on the day? She goes, Oh, my God, I don't remember. Oh, my God, I love that speech. And sadly, it wasn't mine. I'm going to start texting people. Please hold. Oh, I love this so much. This happened throughout the day. She said, I texted rain. Rain actually thinks it was an alt pitched from Paul. Jen said, here's a side note.
准备好了吗？所以我说，好吧，简，德怀特关于吸收他双胞胎的演讲不在剧本里。那是即兴创作吗？你那天告诉他的吗？她说，哦，天哪，我不记得了。哦，天哪，我喜欢那个演讲。遗憾的是，那不是我的。我要开始给人们发短信了。请稍等。哦，我太喜欢这个了。这整天都在发生。她说，我给雷恩发了短信。雷恩实际上认为那是保罗提出的一个替代方案。简说，这是一个侧记。
I had a friend that reabsorbed his twin, but I definitely didn't come up with the strength of a baby. She said, I'm gonna check with Paul where that part came from. Please hold. She texts Paul. Paul says he thinks it was Justin Spitzer. Hold one second. Now texting Justin. Justin says he thinks it was Justin Spitzer. Hold one second, now
我有一个朋友重新吸收了他的双胞胎，但我绝对没有想出婴儿的力量。她说，我要去和保罗核实一下那部分是从哪里来的。请稍等。她给保罗发短信。保罗说他认为那是贾斯汀·斯皮策。稍等一秒。现在给贾斯汀发短信。贾斯汀说他认为那是贾斯汀·斯皮策。稍等一秒，现在
texting Justin. Justin was another one of our writers. This is what Justin texted Jen back. I still remember that because it was early season three and I was so nervous about proving myself. I guess yes, I came up with it. But the thing that really sold it to me was the last line about him having the strength of a grown man plus a baby. And that was something that Paul Lieberstein added after. So I think he deserves a fair amount of credit as well. So I'm giving that a slow clap slow. A big clap.
给贾斯汀发短信。贾斯汀是我们另一位编剧。这是贾斯汀回给珍的短信。我至今还记得，因为那是第三季初期，我当时非常紧张，急于证明自己。我想是的，是我提出来的。但真正打动我的是最后那句关于他拥有成年人和婴儿双重力量的台词。那是保罗·利伯斯坦后来加进去的。所以我认为他也理应获得相当多的赞誉。所以我给这个点子鼓个掌，慢节奏的掌声。热烈的掌声。
Yes. Wow. It was a two-hander that Paul and Justin pitched. I love that we got to the bottom of that mystery because it is one of my all-time favorite Dwightisms. Also guys, Justin Spitzer is the creator of the show Superstore. Justin is so talented. He's so talented.
是的。哇。那是保罗和贾斯汀共同提出的双人戏。我很高兴我们弄清了那个谜团，因为这是我个人最喜欢的“德怀特主义”之一。另外，伙计们，贾斯汀·斯皮策是美剧《超市特工》的创作者。贾斯汀太有才了。他真的太有才了。
I love him. Love him. Anyway. talented. He's so talented. I love him. Love him. Anyway, I think the only place to go from here is back to our grief circle. And we need to hear from some others. Okay, so we're back into the grief counseling scene. And Stanley has just refused. He is not going to participate. Now chunks that ball back at Michael. Hey, yeah, you heard that. Yeah, you heard that. I heard that. But Pam agrees to participate, and she's going to share a story about her family, but it's clearly just the synopsis for the movie Million Dollar Baby.
我爱他。爱他。总之。有才。他太有才了。我爱他。爱他。总之，我觉得从这里开始，唯一能去的地方就是回到我们的悲伤辅导圈。我们需要听听其他人的想法。好的，我们回到了悲伤辅导的场景。斯坦利刚刚拒绝了。他不打算参与。现在把球扔回给迈克尔。嘿，是的，你听到了。是的，你听到了。我听到了。但帕姆同意参与，她要分享一个关于她家庭的故事，但这显然只是电影《百万美元宝贝》的剧情梗概。
Yeah. I mean, again, Pam is now the gem. She's the jokester. Yes. And then Ryan joins in, and he shares a story that is very clearly the Lion King. I mean, he says the word Mufasa. I mean, come on. But then Kevin catches on, and he's tickled.
是的。我的意思是，再说一次，帕姆现在是瑰宝。她是那个爱开玩笑的人。是的。然后瑞安加入了，他分享了一个非常明显的《狮子王》的故事。我的意思是，他说了“木法沙”这个词。我的意思是，拜托。但随后凯文听出来了，他被逗乐了。
He wants to participate. He wants to play the game. But he goes too broad, too on the nose, and he basically breaks down Weekend at Bernie's. And Michael's like, what? Hold up. That's a movie. And he gets really ticked off. OK, so there was a lot of curiosity
他想参与。他想玩这个游戏。但他讲得太宽泛、太直白了，他基本上把《老板度假去》的剧情讲了出来。迈克尔说，什么？等等。那是部电影。他真的很生气。好吧，所以当时大家对会议室里的这些电影情节感到很好奇。
about these movie plots in the conference room. We got a fan question from Tristan, who wants to know, when everyone is in the conference room for Michael's counseling session, did the cast improvise the movie plots that were mentioned, or were they scripted? Jenna, to my knowledge, they were all scripted. That's how I remember it. Yes, I looked these up in the shooting draft and
我们收到了特里斯坦的一个粉丝提问，他想知道，当大家都在会议室参加迈克尔的辅导课时，提到的电影情节是演员即兴发挥的，还是写在剧本里的？珍娜，据我所知，它们都是写在剧本里的。我是这么记得的。是的，我在拍摄草稿里查过了，
Pam's Million Dollar Baby Story and Kevin's Weekend at Bernie's Story are both in the script. However, Ryan's fake movie story is different. Ah, yes. In the script, he talks about Thelma and Louise. Well, this is what he says. He says, my mom's sister Thelma and Louise. This is what he says.
帕姆的《百万美元宝贝》故事和凯文的《老板度假去》故事都在剧本里。然而，瑞安的虚构电影故事不同。啊，是的。在剧本里，他讲的是《末路狂花》。嗯，他是这么说的。他说，我妈妈的姐妹塞尔玛和路易丝。他是这么说的。
He says, My mom's sister Thelma died last year. She was with her friend named Lucy. A cop was trying to pull them over, and I guess the brakes must have not been working because they ended up driving over a cliff, and it was a total shock to everyone. Okay, well, we wanted to get to the bottom of this, so we reached out to the source,
他说，我妈妈的姐妹塞尔玛去年去世了。她和她的朋友露西在一起。警察试图拦下她们，我想刹车肯定失灵了，因为她们最后开车冲下了悬崖，这对每个人来说都是一个巨大的打击。好吧，我们想弄清真相，所以我们联系了消息来源，
the writer of this episode, Jen Salata, and this is what she had to say. For the movies in the grief counseling session, I was really excited. It was really fun to think about. I went off on script and needed to find a way that everybody would sit there with Michael Scott and not share their own personal stories of huge loss. Because it just didn't seem like they would do that. So I thought they should share movie plot lines as if they were their own lives.
这一集的编剧珍·萨拉塔，她是这么说的。对于悲伤辅导环节里的电影，我真的很兴奋。想这些真的很有趣。我脱离了剧本，需要找到一种方法，让每个人都坐在迈克尔·斯科特身边，而不是分享他们自己关于巨大损失的个人故事。因为看起来他们似乎不会那样做。所以我认为他们应该分享电影情节，就好像那是他们自己的生活一样。
And I came up with Million Dollar Baby for you, Jennifer Pam, and Dollar Baby for you, Jennifer, Pam, and then also for Kevin, Weekend at Bernie's. And for Ryan, I had a different one. I think BJ came up with The Lion King. I don't quite remember, but I think it was BJ, and I love that one. The one I had,
我为你，珍妮弗·帕姆，想到了《百万美元宝贝》，然后也为凯文想到了《老板度假去》。至于瑞安，我有一个不同的版本。我想是BJ想到了《狮子王》。我记不太清了，但我认为是BJ，我很喜欢那个。我原本有的那个，
I actually found my first draft of the script. I had Ryan, I'll redo the line. It's not as good as The Lion King one, I actually found my first draft of the script. I had Ryan, I'll read you the line. It's not as good as the Lion King one, but I have Ryan say, this is almost too horrible to talk about, but I had a cousin who was a big city lawyer and he was visiting an Amish town not far from here and he was smothered to death in their grain silo.
我实际上找到了我的第一版剧本。我让瑞安讲的，我重读一下那句台词。它没有《狮子王》那个好，我实际上找到了我的第一版剧本。我让瑞安讲的，我读给你听。它没有《狮子王》那个好，但我让瑞安说，这太可怕了，简直没法说，但我有个表亲是个大城市的律师，他去了一个离这儿不远的阿米什小镇，结果在他们的粮仓里被闷死了。
And then I had Michael say, ooh, that must have made you really sad, did it? And Ryan says, yes. So I think that was a witness. So I had Ryan's from Witness. I wish I could remember some of the other ones because I feel like we had other ones that we pitched on, but those were the ones from my first draft.
然后我让迈克尔说，噢，那一定让你很难过，是吗？瑞安说，是的。所以我认为那是《证人》。所以我让瑞安讲的是《证人》。我真希望我能记得其他的一些，因为我觉得我们还构思了其他的，但那些是我第一版剧本里的。
And then of course, the line King's Circle of Life was fantastic. And Ryan saying, it'll take about an hour and a half to tell it was like such a great line. That is amazing. By the way, my college roommate and I used to watch Witness and we would say to each other all the time,
然后当然，《狮子王》里的“生生不息”太棒了。瑞安说“讲完它大概需要一个半小时”真是一句绝妙的台词。那太神奇了。顺便说一句，我和我的大学室友过去常看《证人》，我们总是对彼此说，
be careful out among them English. Thank you. That is my movie quote from Witness. But isn't that wild Jenna that Ryan's movie went through three versions. It was Witness and then it was, I guess Thelma and Louise according to your script, but the Lion King is what made it in the show. Yeah clearly they had a lot of alts for these movie plots but all of them were scripted guys all of them written by our awesome writers. We did not
“在他们这些英国人中间要小心。”谢谢。那是我的《证人》电影台词。但珍娜，瑞安的电影情节经历了三个版本，这不是很疯狂吗？先是《证人》，然后根据你的剧本是《末路狂花》，但最终出现在剧集里的是《狮子王》。是的，显然他们为这些电影情节准备了很多备选，但伙计们，它们全都是写在剧本里的，全都是由我们出色的编剧写的。我们没有
improvise that stuff. Love that love that little tidbit Jen Salata. So guys, Michael gets pretty upset that people are not taking this seriously. You know, he says the guy who used to do his job and sit at his desk has died and no one cares. Yeah. And Toby tries to talk him down and tries to explain that this is just life and that this morning he saw a bird fly into the window downstairs and die. Michael freaks out. Oh my gosh, Toby. Toby, what are you thinking?
即兴发挥那些东西。喜欢那个，喜欢那个小花絮，珍·萨拉塔。所以伙计们，迈克尔对大家没有认真对待这件事感到非常沮丧。你知道，他说那个曾经做他工作、坐在他办公桌前的人去世了，却没人关心。是的。托比试图劝他冷静下来，试图解释这就是生活，今天早上他看到一只鸟飞进楼下的窗户死掉了。迈克尔吓坏了。噢，天哪，托比。托比，你在想什么？
He totally attaches to that. Now Michael's grief for Ed is somehow wrapped into this bird. It's going to be a whole thing. Yeah. He runs downstairs. He freaks out. He wants to see if the bird is alive. It's gonna be a whole thing. Yeah. He runs downstairs. He freaks out. He wants to see if the bird is alive.
他完全被那个吸引住了。现在迈克尔对埃德的悲伤不知怎么地被包裹进了这只鸟里。这会变成一件大事。是的。他跑下楼。他吓坏了。他想看看那只鸟是否还活着。这会变成一件大事。是的。他跑下楼。他吓坏了。他想看看那只鸟是否还活着。
I had a fan catch here from Kendra. At 14 minutes 33 seconds when Michael runs through the front door to get the bird, he runs past the security desk and the security guard is not Hank. Oh, good catch. Yeah, different security guard. Hank took a personal day, you guys. I guess so. Well, Michael attempts to resuscitate the bird in the kitchen.
我这里有一个来自肯德拉的粉丝发现。在14分33秒，当迈克尔跑过前门去抓那只鸟时，他跑过了保安台，那个保安不是汉克。噢，好眼力。是的，不同的保安。汉克请了事假，伙计们。我想是吧。好吧，迈克尔试图在厨房里抢救那只鸟。
Angela, you're not pleased. So Michael is determined to save this bird. He brings it into the kitchen. Angela Martin is not pleased. She's like, no, that shouldn't be in here. Get it out. Well, she is not pleased, and Angela, she's not wrong. Thank you.
安吉拉，你不高兴。所以迈克尔决心救这只鸟。他把它带进了厨房。安吉拉·马丁很不高兴。她说，不，那不应该在这里。把它弄出去。好吧，她很不高兴，而且安吉拉，她说得没错。谢谢。
Thank you, Jenna. Yes. You're welcome. You're welcome. We had a fan question from Ellie Friedlander. She wants to know, was that a real dead bird? No. No.
谢谢你，珍娜。是的。不客气。不客气。我们收到了艾莉·弗里德兰德的一个粉丝提问。她想知道，那是一只真正的死鸟吗？不。不。
No, Ellie. It was a fake bird. I reached out to Phil, he told me that he found three dead fake bird options and presented them to Jen, Roger, our director, and Greg. They chose the one that you see in the show. And Angela, I have to say, when he texted me back that he presented the three dead birds, I imagined in my head that they were on a silver tray because remember Phil would always present you your props on a silver tray. Yes, yes. And
不，艾莉。那是一只假鸟。我联系了菲尔，他告诉我他找到了三个死假鸟的选项，并把它们展示给了珍、罗杰（我们的导演）和格雷格。他们选择了你在剧中看到的那一个。安吉拉，我不得不说，当他回短信告诉我他展示了那三只死鸟时，我在脑海里想象它们是在一个银盘子上的，因为记得菲尔总是会用银盘子给你展示道具。是的，是的。而且
I was just imagining it. I wrote him back and I said, Phil, were they on a silver tray? And he said, you know me too well. These are the moments in our show where I'm like, hey babe, how was your day? What'd you do today? Well, I had to find three fake dead birds. Yeah. I scoured. Or like, when Greg goes home and his wife Susie and is like, hey hun, how'd it go shooting today? He's like, great, I picked a dead bird.
我当时就在想象那个画面。我回信说，菲尔，它们是在银盘子上吗？他说，你太了解我了。这些就是我们节目中让我觉得，嘿宝贝，你今天过得怎么样？你今天做了什么？嗯，我得找三只假死鸟。是的。我搜寻了。或者就像格雷格回家，他妻子苏西问，嘿亲爱的，今天拍摄怎么样？他说，太棒了，我选了一只死鸟。
Yeah. I picked the yellow one. I made my dead bird selection. Yes, exactly. Well, Michael then tells the staff, attention, attention, we are holding a funeral for this bird at 4 p.m. in the parking lot. Be there. It's on. Jenna, now I think it's time to check back in on Jim and Karen. Oh yes. Have they found the chips? Where are they? Where are they in
是的。我选了黄色的那只。我做出了我的死鸟选择。是的，完全正确。好吧，迈克尔然后告诉员工，注意，注意，我们将在下午4点在停车场为这只鸟举行葬礼。一定要到。开始了。珍娜，现在我觉得是时候看看吉姆和凯伦的情况了。噢，是的。他们找到薯片了吗？它们在哪儿？它们在
their search for this very hard to find potato chip bag? That's actually in the vending machine. That might be in the vending machine. That is in the vending machine. According to a fan catch is B1 in the vending machine. Yeah it's right there waiting for them. Well Karen kind of impresses Jim because she decides to call Montreal, the Montreal factory to see if they have them. And she speaks French. May we?
他们寻找这袋非常难找的薯片的过程中？其实就在自动售货机里。那可能在自动售货机里。那就在自动售货机里。根据粉丝的发现，是自动售货机里的B1。是的，它就在那里等着他们。好吧，凯伦让吉姆印象深刻，因为她决定给蒙特利尔，蒙特利尔工厂打电话，看看他们是否有货。而且她说法语。我们可以吗？
May we, may we. A lot of people wrote in about this. Brianna Bullard and many, many others want to know, does Rashida Jones actually know French? So I texted Rashida, since we're already texting about her breakfast order, she's probably like, Angela, what is happening? This is what she said. She goes, no, at this time I didn't know French. I worked really hard on that line. But a few years later I ended up going to France to do a French immersion school in the
我们可以，我们可以。很多人写信问这件事。布里安娜·布拉德和许多许多其他人想知道，拉什达·琼斯真的懂法语吗？所以我给拉什达发了短信，既然我们已经在聊她的早餐订单了，她可能在想，安吉拉，发生了什么？她是这么说的。她说，不，当时我不懂法语。我为那句台词付出了很多努力。但几年后，我最终去了法国，在法国南部参加了一个法语沉浸式学校。
south of France. Maybe this scene was the beginning and it got me inspired. Wow! That's crazy! She did not speak French, but now she does. Yes, I was like, I want to go to a French immersion class in the south of France. That sounds amazing. Same. Same. I took French in high school. You did. Oh, I have a story about that actually. Yeah. Can I tell this real quickly? Yeah. I took French in high school from sister Landry. I went to a Catholic school. Sister Landry was my French teacher and I dreamed,
也许这一幕是开始，它启发了我。哇！太疯狂了！她不会说法语，但现在会了。是的，我当时想，我想去法国南部参加法语沉浸式课程。听起来太棒了。我也是。我也是。我在高中学过法语。你学过。噢，我其实有个关于那个的故事。是的。我能快速讲一下吗？是的。我在高中时跟着兰德里修女学法语。我上的是天主教学校。兰德里修女是我的法语老师，我梦想着，
I told you guys this before. I dreamed from the time I was a little girl that I would one day go to Paris. And then in my thirties that finally happened. Of course, guys this before, I dreamed from the time I was a little girl that I would one day go to Paris. And then in my 30s, that finally happened. Of course, at this point, I was now very far from my French training. Couldn't really speak French. But Lee and I, we went to a little farmer's market. And I guess in France, you don't touch the fruit.
我之前跟你们说过。我从小就梦想着有一天能去巴黎。然后在三十多岁时，那终于实现了。当然，我之前跟你们说过，我从小就梦想着有一天能去巴黎。然后在三十多岁时，那终于实现了。当然，此时此刻，我离我的法语训练已经很远了。真的不会说法语了。但李和我，我们去了一个小农贸市场。我想在法国，你不能碰水果。
Uh oh. Okay? You don't select your own produce. You point to it or you trust the person selling the produce to select the best pieces for you. I didn't know this. Okay. Oh my gosh.
噢，不。好吧？你不能自己挑选农产品。你指着它，或者你信任卖农产品的人为你挑选最好的。我不知道这一点。好吧。噢，天哪。
I would have been, I pick up things, I thump them, I smell them. No lady, don't do it. If you go to a farmer's market in France, here's my hot tip for you. Don't touch that fruit. Don't thump the market in France, here's my hot tip for you. Do not touch that fruit. Don't sump the melon. Don't sump the melon in France, okay? Now all through this trip we've been going to restaurants and we've been going to tourist places and I was just fumbling with my French.
我会的，我拿起东西，我敲敲它们，我闻闻它们。不，女士，别那样做。如果你去法国的农贸市场，这是我给你的小贴士。别碰那个水果。别敲那个瓜。在法国别敲那个瓜，好吗？现在在整个旅行中，我们一直在去餐馆，一直在去旅游景点，我一直在用我的法语笨拙地交流。
I couldn't get anything out. I could read the menus but I couldn't order anything. I thought I was going to really help us but I couldn't help us. But here we are. We're at this little market. I have done the faux pas, I believe that's French, the faux pas of touching the fruit. And this woman turns to her coworker and goes off on me. She in French is calling me like kind of like a dumb American.
我什么都说不出来。我能读懂菜单，但我什么都点不了。我以为我真的能帮上忙，但我帮不上忙。但我们就在这里。我们在市场里。我犯了失礼，我相信那是法语，触碰水果的失礼。这个女人转向她的同事，开始对我发火。她用法语骂我，大概就像是个愚蠢的美国人。
in French is calling me like kind of like a dumb American. Yeah basically whatever it was just these Americans come here and they touch her fruit. She was like going on and on okay in French. I was this mixture of just like embarrassed but also felt like I sorry, how was I supposed to know that? I'm a nice person. I'm not a bad person, I'm sorry I picked up that banana. And Angela, this fluent French spilled out of my mouth at this woman, and in French I suddenly had the command to say, I'm so sorry, but in the United States, we pick our own fruit. I didn't know about your custom. I apologize, but you don't need to say nasty things about me. And the look on her face was like, oh!
用法语骂我，大概就像是个愚蠢的美国人。是的，基本上不管是什么，就是这些美国人来到这里，他们碰她的水果。她一直在用法语说个不停，好吧。我当时处于一种既尴尬又觉得抱歉的混合情绪中，我怎么会知道那个？我是个好人。我不是坏人，对不起我拿起了那个香蕉。安吉拉，这流利的法语从我嘴里喷涌而出，对着这个女人，我突然有能力用法语说，我很抱歉，但在美国，我们自己挑选水果。我不知道你们的习俗。我道歉，但你不需要说关于我的难听话。她脸上的表情就像是，噢！
Because she certainly didn't think that the fruit-touching American could speak French or understand French. And by the way, I didn't know that I had such a command of the language until I was insulted in a farmer's market in Paris. And then your superpower came out.
因为她肯定没想到那个碰水果的美国人会说法语或听懂法语。顺便说一句，我不知道我竟然有这么好的语言掌控力，直到我在巴黎的农贸市场被侮辱。然后你的超能力就显现出来了。
Yes. You know how like some superheroes, their power doesn't come through until they're in crisis. I was like a mom lifting a car off her baby. Yeah, exactly. All right, so now we're back at Dunder Mifflin and Kelly is crying by the copier in the annex. Yeah, exactly. All right, so now we're back at Dunder Mifflin and Kelly is crying by the copier in the annex. Yeah. She is in tears. Michael thinks he's finally made a breakthrough
是的。你知道有些超级英雄，他们的力量直到危机时刻才会显现。我就像一个把车从孩子身上抬起来的妈妈。是的，完全正确。好了，现在我们回到邓德·米夫林，凯莉在附件的复印机旁哭泣。是的，完全正确。好了，现在我们回到邓德·米夫林，凯莉在附件的复印机旁哭泣。是的。她泪流满面。迈克尔认为他终于取得了突破，
until she reveals that she's really crying about her plans with Ryan. I have a question about this scene. Okay. What is up with this second copier in the annex? Is it always there? I have never seen it before. What is happening? I think they just rolled it in from the bullpen for the scene. I feel like they did and they did it because in the background, in the break room, Dwight is in there.
直到她透露她其实是因为她和瑞安的计划而哭。关于这一幕我有个问题。好的。附件里的这第二台复印机是怎么回事？它一直都在那儿吗？我从来没见过它。发生了什么？我觉得他们只是为了这一幕把它从大办公室推过来的。我觉得他们是这样做的，而且他们这样做是因为在背景里，在休息室里，德怀特在那儿。
You can see him over Kelly's shoulder trying to shove this bird into an empty soda can. I feel like that's why they had to put the copier there to combine these two moments, to have a reason for Michael to be back there. Right. And for him to see over his shoulder and all of that. Exactly. That copier did not live there in that hallway.
你可以看到他在凯莉的肩膀后面，试图把这只鸟塞进一个空的汽水罐里。我觉得这就是他们必须把复印机放在那儿的原因，为了结合这两个时刻，为了给迈克尔一个回到那儿的理由。对。为了让他能从肩膀后面看到这一切。完全正确。那台复印机平时不住在那个走廊里。
They just shoved it there. Thank you. Yeah. I did not think so. I feel like I will track this. It's going to be a soft track, but I am going to look for this copy or more. I think it should be a very soft track because I would be bold enough to say, I think it might be the only time it's in the Annex.
他们只是把它推到了那儿。谢谢。是的。我没觉得它在那儿。我觉得我会追踪这个。这会是一个软追踪，但我会更多地留意这台复印机。我觉得它应该是一个非常软的追踪，因为我敢大胆地说，我觉得这可能是它唯一一次出现在附件里。
I know that's setting that's setting myself up for some fan mail of like Angela actually in season eight. But I'm just saying I don't I don't think that copier visits the annex very often. All right. But this leads us into one of my favorite Dwight Talkingheads, where he explains he's justifying why is he shoving this bird into a can, and it's because he grew up on a farm. Yeah. And guys, they reburied his grandfather in an old oil drum.
我知道这会让我收到一些粉丝邮件，比如“安吉拉，其实在第八季……”。但我只是说，我不觉得那台复印机经常去附件。好了。但这引出了我最喜欢的德怀特访谈之一，他解释并证明了为什么他要把这只鸟塞进罐子里，因为他在农场长大。是的。而且伙计们，他们把他的祖父重新埋进了一个旧油桶里。
Okay, hold on. I mean, the same grandfather that was buried in the suit that he wore, like, what's happening? How many times has this guy been brought up out of the ground? This is one of my favorite things about our show. Teresa S. also loves it. She wrote in to say, in Casino Night, Dwight says that his grandfather was buried in the tuxedo he's wearing. And in Grief Counseling, he said his grandfather was reburied in an oil drum.
好吧，等等。我的意思是，同一个祖父，埋葬时穿着他穿的那套西装，就像，发生了什么？这家伙被从地里挖出来多少次了？这是我们节目中我最喜欢的事情之一。特蕾莎·S也喜欢它。她写信说，在《赌场之夜》，德怀特说他的祖父穿着他穿的那件燕尾服下葬。而在《悲伤辅导》中，他说他的祖父被重新埋进了一个油桶里。
Reburied? She wrote reburied. What happened? What is the story behind Dwight's grandfather? Was he exhumed for some reason? And did Dwight take the tuxedo off his dead grandfather before reburying him? And then fold him up? It sounds like it.
重新埋葬？她写的是重新埋葬。发生了什么？德怀特祖父背后的故事是什么？他是因为什么原因被掘出的吗？德怀特在重新埋葬他之前，有没有把燕尾服从他死去的祖父身上脱下来？然后把他折叠起来？听起来是这样。
Then he folded him up and tried to shove him in a drum. Teresa, that's exactly what it sounds like. This is some of my favorite writing on our show. In that moment in Casino Night when Dwight just says he's wearing a tuxedo, my grandfather was buried in it. That's it. We say no more about it. And then three episodes later, he's like when my grandfather was reburied.
然后他把他折叠起来，试图把他塞进一个桶里。特蕾莎，听起来确实是这样。这是我们节目中我最喜欢的一些剧本。在《赌场之夜》那一刻，当德怀特只是说他穿着燕尾服，我祖父穿着它下葬。就是这样。我们没再多说。然后三集之后，他说“当我祖父被重新埋葬时”。
And it's like slowly it's all coming together. Sort of. Not completely. It's one of my favorite bits of how our show is written. So now we're at reception, right? And Pam has prepared this really beautiful box for the bird funeral. I mean, it is amazing. The attention to detail. She asked Dwight if he would perhaps want to play a song. She's like, do you have your recorder? He's like, always, always has. Always. Always. And Pam has this really sweet talking head
就像慢慢地一切都拼凑在一起了。某种程度上。不完全是。这是我们节目剧本写作方式中我最喜欢的部分之一。所以现在我们在前台，对吧？帕姆为鸟葬礼准备了这个非常漂亮的盒子。我的意思是，它太棒了。对细节的关注。她问德怀特是否想吹一首歌。她说，你有你的竖笛吗？他说，一直都有，一直都有。一直。一直。帕姆有一个非常甜蜜的访谈，
where she's like, well, you know what? I didn't anticipate I'd be throwing a bird funeral today, but you never know, working here. That's right. We had a fan question from Andrew S. Did Jenna make the box for the bird funeral herself, or was that a Phil Shea creation? Either way, how was it constructed? Well guys, I did not make it. Phil Shea made it. He said he
她说，嗯，你知道吗？我没预料到今天会举办一场鸟葬礼，但你永远不知道，在这里工作。没错。我们收到了安德鲁·S的一个粉丝提问。珍娜是自己制作了鸟葬礼的盒子，还是那是菲尔·谢的作品？无论哪种方式，它是怎么制作的？好吧伙计们，不是我做的。是菲尔·谢做的。他说他
actually made a few options and presented them again to Jen and Roger and Greg. They picked the one that they liked and then Phil had to make multiples of it because you know, it gets set on fire. Yeah. So he had to make a whole bunch of those. I looked it up in the script and it was described in the script so here's what Phil had to go off of. It said it is a hollowed out tissue box with tissue padding in the center for the bird to lie on and the outside is decorated in tissue paper and has a tiny little toothpick cross. paper and has a tiny little toothpick cross. My favorite part are the the handles. The handles made out of the pencils. So that was a Phil edition. That was just Phil. Yeah, yeah. He needed to make sure that tiny bird casket had
实际上做了几个选项，再次展示给了珍、罗杰和格雷格。他们选了他们喜欢的那个，然后菲尔不得不制作多个，因为你知道，它会被点火。是的。所以他不得不制作了一大堆。我在剧本里查过了，剧本里有描述，所以菲尔是根据这个做的。它说这是一个掏空的纸巾盒，中间有纸巾垫，让鸟躺在上面，外面用纸巾装饰，还有一个小小的牙签十字架。我最喜欢的部分是把手。用铅笔做的把手。所以那是菲尔的加成。那只是菲尔。是的，是的。他需要确保那个小鸟棺材有
little bars for his the pallbearers. The tiny pallbearers. Yes we are gonna wrap things up in Stanford now guys. Jim found the chips. He left them on her desk. He's quite pleased with himself. Yeah I really wanted my mom to record a sting that said flirty Jim but we we couldn't we couldn't get it together. Oh well these scenes drove people crazy. I went back and looked at some of the comments from when this aired. Here is what they said. D-Temp said, I feel kind of weird about Jim and Karen.
小小的杠杆给他的护柩者。小小的护柩者。是的，我们现在要在斯坦福结束了，伙计们。吉姆找到了薯片。他把它们留在了她的桌子上。他对自己很满意。是的，我真的很想让我妈妈录一段音，说“调情的吉姆”，但我们没能搞定。噢，好吧，这些场景让人们抓狂。我回去看了看播出时的一些评论。这是他们说的。D-Temp说，我对吉姆和凯伦感觉有点奇怪。
But Hartman said, the Karen thing? Why oh why am I liking it, but I am. Whoa. I remember people freaking out about it. Well, Keely said, Jim and Karen have great chemistry. And Mandy said, OK, I'm sorry. I can't believe there are actually people out there who are OK with Jim hooking up with Karen.
但哈特曼说，凯伦那件事？为什么，噢，为什么我喜欢它，但我确实喜欢。哇。我记得人们对此感到抓狂。好吧，基利说，吉姆和凯伦很有化学反应。曼迪说，好吧，对不起。我不敢相信真的有人能接受吉姆和凯伦在一起。
That's what I remember. But Kim E said this. Hmm, Jim likes to buy chips for all his ladies. And I'm with you, Kim. As Pam, I'm like, oh, is this what you do? You just find all the girls their favorite chips? Yeah, that's his game. Are we saying that right?
这就是我记得的。但金·E说了这个。嗯，吉姆喜欢为他所有的女士买薯片。我和你一样，金。作为帕姆，我在想，噢，这就是你做的吗？你只是为所有的女孩找到她们最喜欢的薯片？是的，那是他的游戏。我们说对了吗？
Oh, is that your game? You and I? I 100% doubt we are. Sam's giving us an okay. Sam gave us an okay. That's his game. All right, should we go to this bird funeral, Angela? I can't wait. Please take me there. Well, we're out in the driveway, really, next to the warehouse. This was an actual parking lot that we used and it was right next to the warehouse and that's where we filmed this. Michael is very moved by Pam's beautiful coffin. It starts with Pam saying a few words about the bird but we slowly realize that Pam is speaking about the bird but she's speaking to Michael. About his feelings, about death and loss. And about his aloneness. She talks a lot about how
噢，那是你的游戏吗？你和我？我100%怀疑我们是。萨姆给了我们一个OK。萨姆给了我们一个OK。那是他的游戏。好了，我们去参加这个鸟葬礼吗，安吉拉？我等不及了。请带我去那儿。好吧，我们在车道上，其实是在仓库旁边。这是一个我们使用的实际停车场，它就在仓库旁边，那就是我们拍摄的地方。迈克尔被帕姆漂亮的棺材深深打动了。它以帕姆说几句关于鸟的话开始，但我们慢慢意识到帕姆是在谈论鸟，但她是在对迈克尔说话。关于他的感受，关于死亡和失去。以及关于他的孤独。她谈了很多关于
just because the bird was alone doesn't mean he was unloved. Mm-hmm. That he was very loved and respected by the other birds. And then she sings a song. I was very surprised by this for Pam. She really put herself out there. She sings on the wings of love. She's accompanied by Dwight on the recorder. Michael is very moved. He's holding hands, he's swaying, he's tearing up. We got a lot of questions about this scene. Richard H. really covers them all. He says, did Rain already know how to play the recorder? Did Jenna sing the entire song or did the singing end where the scene was cut? He also wanted to know did we rehearse our duet? Here's what I can tell you. Yes, Rain knew how to
仅仅因为鸟是孤独的并不意味着它不被爱。嗯哼。它非常被其他鸟类爱戴和尊重。然后她唱了一首歌。这对帕姆来说让我非常惊讶。她真的展现了自己。她唱了《在爱的翅膀上》。她由德怀特用竖笛伴奏。迈克尔非常感动。他握着手，摇摆着，流着泪。我们收到了很多关于这一幕的问题。理查德·H真的涵盖了所有这些。他说，雷恩本来就知道怎么吹竖笛吗？珍娜是唱了整首歌，还是歌声在场景剪辑处结束了？他还想知道我们排练过我们的二重唱吗？这是我可以告诉你的。是的，雷恩知道怎么
play the recorder. Remember he played it in Take Your Daughter to Work Day. He's actually very good. But listen to all of the instruments that Rain can play in real life, Angela. He can play the recorder, piano, clarinet, saxophone, bassoon, guitar, drums, xylophone, bells, and a little tuba and baritone. What are you, a one-man band, Rain? He kind of is. I knew you could play the bassoon because your book, The Bassoon King, is great, so I knew that. But I didn't know you were walking one-man show.
吹竖笛。记得他在《带女儿上班日》里吹过吗？他其实吹得很好。但听听雷恩在现实生活中能演奏的所有乐器，安吉拉。他会吹竖笛、钢琴、单簧管、萨克斯、巴松管、吉他、鼓、木琴、铃铛，还有一点大号和男中音号。你是什么，一人乐队吗，雷恩？他确实有点像。我知道你会吹巴松管，因为你的书《巴松管之王》很棒，所以我知道那个。但我不知道你是一个行走的单人秀。
Suffice it to say, Rain knew his stuff. And we did rehearse, but just a little bit right before the scene. Rain and I practiced separately. I had listened to the song over and over again to memorize the words. I had to sing the first verse through the chorus. That's what I had to do over and over again. I was so nervous. Well I thought you did fantastic. Thank you. I have a fan question from the scene, Jenna. Okay. So Chelsea wrote in and said, was Angela's A-Man improvised? A lot of people wrote in about this because it was so quick after Pam was done talking.
总之，雷恩很在行。我们确实排练过，但就在场景开始前排练了一点点。雷恩和我分开练习。我把那首歌听了一遍又一遍来背歌词。我不得不一遍又一遍地唱第一段到副歌。我当时太紧张了。好吧，我觉得你表现得太棒了。谢谢。我有一个来自这一幕的粉丝提问，珍娜。好的。切尔西写信说，安吉拉的“阿门”是即兴发挥的吗？很多人写信问这件事，因为它在帕姆说完话后太快了。
People wanted to know if I improvised that. No, that was scripted. And folks wanted to know why did Angela do it? And I said, I think personally, the direction that they gave me was that Angela had had enough of this charade, this bird funeral. Pam had gone on and on, enough. Amen. I want, I'm done. And that's how you finish it. Yes. Amen. I'm finished.
人们想知道我是不是即兴发挥的。不，那是写在剧本里的。人们想知道为什么安吉拉要那样做？我说，我个人认为，他们给我的指导是安吉拉已经受够了这个闹剧，这个鸟葬礼。帕姆说个没完没了，够了。阿门。我想要，我受够了。这就是你结束它的方式。是的。阿门。我结束了。
Amen. Stop talking. Yes, exactly. Speaking of the script, I have a script catch. Okay. So, you know, in the scene we set the box on fire. In the shooting draft of the script, we buried the bird. There was a scene where Michael and Dwight are digging a hole outside, and then we all gather around this hole. And it got changed to fire, but I don't know why. I think maybe, Angela, there was really no grass in this area
阿门。别说了。是的，完全正确。说到剧本，我有一个剧本发现。好的。所以，你知道在这一幕里我们把盒子点着了。在剧本的拍摄草稿里，我们埋葬了那只鸟。有一个场景是迈克尔和德怀特在外面挖洞，然后我们都聚集在这个洞周围。它被改成了火，但我不知道为什么。我想也许，安吉拉，这个区域真的没有草
that we shot. We had no grass. There was a hedge with maybe, like, I don't know, three feet of dirt. Like, yeah, there was, I mean, not even. There is a deleted scene where Michael and Dwight are trying to dig a hole there and then the business on the other side yells at them and they run away. Oh, okay. Well, there you go. Well, we had another fan question about this fire then. Clara Johnson wants to know, did you actually set the bird on fire? Yes.
我们拍摄的地方。我们没有草。那里有一个树篱，大概有，我不知道，三英尺的土。就像，是的，我的意思是，甚至都没有。有一个被删减的场景是迈克尔和德怀特试图在那里挖一个洞，然后另一边的人对他们大喊大叫，他们就跑开了。噢，好吧。好吧，给你。好吧，我们关于这场火还有另一个粉丝提问。克拉拉·约翰逊想知道，你们真的把鸟点着了吗？是的。
Real fire, fake bird. Kent told me they had to hire a special effects guy to oversee the fire and the extinguishing, and they had to get a special permit to be allowed to set the fire. And he said we did three takes. Three takes of the fire and Phil told me though that the special effects guys were worried that the fake dead bird might give off toxic fumes when it burned so we they actually took it out of the box and just put a wad of toilet paper in there oh not toilet paper I
真火，假鸟。肯特告诉我他们不得不雇一个特效师来监督火和灭火，他们不得不获得一个特别许可才能被允许点火。他说我们拍了三次。三次火的拍摄，菲尔告诉我，特效师们担心假死鸟在燃烧时可能会散发出有毒烟雾，所以他们实际上把它从盒子里拿出来，只放了一团卫生纸在里面，噢，不是卫生纸，我
know too soon too soon Angela too soon, Angela. Too soon. And then finally, we had a fan catch from Peter K. He said, I noticed the box was burned in some shredded paper. Could this be further evidence that Pam does use the shredder? Oh, look at that. Nice one, Peter. It would appear so. Well, you know, Jen actually left us a really great message about this scene. And she was talking about the fact
知道太早了，太早了，安吉拉，太早了，安吉拉。太早了。最后，我们收到了彼得·K的一个粉丝发现。他说，我注意到盒子是在一些碎纸里烧掉的。这是否能进一步证明帕姆确实使用碎纸机？噢，看那个。不错，彼得。看来是这样。好吧，你知道，珍其实给我们留了一条关于这一幕的很棒的信息。她在谈论这样一个事实：
that we never got to shoot outside. And when we did, everyone would get really excited. And she explains a little bit about that. So Sam, can you play that? One thing that I remember from the grief counseling episode is that when I went to the sound mix, they were showing us the playback of the episode and it was still a little bit unusual
我们从来没有在外面拍摄过。当我们这样做时，每个人都会非常兴奋。她解释了一点关于那个的情况。所以萨姆，你能播放那个吗？我记得关于悲伤辅导那一集的一件事是，当我去混音时，他们正在给我们看这一集的播放，它仍然有点不寻常
when the characters went outside. It was still a little bit of a treat. So we get to this bird funeral scene and our characters are outside and I just remember hearing kind of an enormous amount of birds and I think that it was because we were outside, it was because we had a bird funeral. It was so exciting for the amazing sound people
当角色们走到外面时。这仍然是一个小小的款待。所以我们到了这个鸟葬礼场景，我们的角色在外面，我只记得听到了一种巨大的鸟叫声，我想这是因为我们在外面，是因为我们举行了鸟葬礼。这对出色的音效人员来说太令人兴奋了，
who do a fantastic job to put a lot of bird noises in because for the longest time when we're inside the office they're just putting dot matrix printer sounds and just faxes and old fashioned office noises. So it must have been such a treat in a field day to be able to go outside and hear birds and especially on theme with the funeral. So I remember, it was a slight exaggeration, but it sounded a little bit like Alfred Hitchcock the Birds when I first heard the playback for the bird funeral. But they quickly made a wonderful adjustment and it was the right amount of outside birds. I love that. I love that our sound mixers got so excited.
他们做得非常棒，放入了很多鸟叫声，因为很长一段时间里，当我们在办公室里面时，他们只是放入点阵打印机的声音和传真机以及老式的办公室噪音。所以能够走到外面听到鸟叫声，特别是在葬礼的主题下，一定是一种款待和狂欢。所以我记得，这有点夸张，但我第一次听到鸟葬礼的播放时，听起来有点像阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克的《鸟》。但他们很快做了一个美妙的调整，那是适量的户外鸟叫声。我喜欢那个。我喜欢我们的混音师变得如此兴奋。
They put like hundreds of birds and they're like, okay guys, there's not that many birds outside. Let's dial it back. Yes. Yes. Oh, what good insight from Jen this week. Yes. Thank you so much, Jen Salata for sending in those clips and for texting me.
他们放了成百上千只鸟，他们就像，好吧伙计们，外面没有那么多鸟。让我们调小一点。是的。是的。噢，珍这周提供了多么好的见解。是的。非常感谢珍·萨拉塔发来这些片段并给我发短信。
You are amazing. We so appreciate it. And thank you, Rashida for letting me bug you about all kinds of random things yesterday. And also Phil Shea and Kent Sabornak. Thank you guys for helping us make this podcast so great. And thanks so much to Mindy Kaling for letting us take a clip from your book, Is Everyone Hanging Out Without Me and Other Concerns? It's hilarious. We love you, Mindy. So there you have it guys. That's the grief counseling episode. Did we do it?
你太棒了。我们非常感激。也谢谢拉什达昨天让我为各种随机的事情烦你。还有菲尔·谢和肯特·萨博纳克。谢谢你们帮助我们让这个播客变得如此棒。也非常感谢敏迪·卡灵让我们从你的书《每个人都在外面玩而不带我及其他担忧》中摘取片段。它太搞笑了。我们爱你，敏迪。所以伙计们，这就是全部。这就是悲伤辅导那一集。我们做到了吗？
Are we leaving you depressed? I hope not. I hope not and hopefully next week we won't have any more dead birds to tell you about in our lives. Stay safe out there, flying friends. Stay safe out there, everyone. We love ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
我们让你感到沮丧了吗？我希望没有。我希望没有，希望下周我们生活中不会再有更多的死鸟要告诉你们了。在外面要小心，飞行的朋友们。在外面要小心，每个人。我们爱你。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。这一集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。
Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。